the house rule 67 in the governor's
emergency order number 12 pursuant to
the executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically this is a public hearing
on bills referred to the committee and
scheduled the house calendar for today
an executive session may be held on any
bill referred to the committee
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporariously to
this meeting however in accordance with
the emergency order i am confirming that
all the members of the committee and
select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate contemporariously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform and the
public has access to contemporaries
listen and if necessary participate in a
meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone
all the necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court website
the notice of this meeting complies with
the house rules and rsa 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing this
meeting should call 271 3600 or email
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote
so let's start by the meeting by taking
a roll call attendance when each member
states their presence please also state
whether there's anyone in the room with
you during this meeting which is
required on the right to know law
okay keith you're on
all right uh ready to call the rule
representative john hunt
i i am here
and i am alone uh and but i do have
grandchildren in the house so if you
hear noises that's what's happening
i like your haircut thank you
representative representative john
patuck
president
representative keith ammon that's me
present and alone
representative max abramson
i'm here president
representative bonnie hamm
president and i'm alone
representative joseph de palma
here and alone
representative jeffrey greeson
president alone
representative dawn johnson
and alone at the moment but i do have
two daughters that are home
remotely today
because of the weather
okay
representative paul terry president i'm
the only person in the room
representative christie bartlett
president alone in the room
representative chris herbert
representative
connie van houten
president alone
representative tina fargo i'm present
i'm alone in the room
representative joyce weston
present and alone in the room
representative jane bellew
president and alone in the room
representative anita burroughs
present alone in the room
and representative chris mcaleer
um present alone in the room
okay that's 18 present mr
uh
representative richard abel's here as
well by myself alone oh did i miss you i
apologize it's okay it's fine all right
well that that makes 18 then
okay we'll open up the public hearing on
house bill 593
and
i'll ask the attendees who are speaking
and i'm uh representing matt wilhelm uh
i'm gonna move you right up here
okay
and good morning representative wilhelm
uh good morning good morning chairman
hunt and honorable members of the house
commerce committee for the record my
name is matt wilhelm i proudly served as
a state representative for the 42nd
district of hillsborough county which
includes manchester central business
district covering downtown and our
historic mill yard
i'm here this morning to introduce house
bill 593 to require a food delivery
service
to enter into an agreement with a food
service establishment or food retail
store before offering delivery service
from that restaurant
while food delivery has become a
lifeline for many new hampshire
restaurants during the covid19 pandemic
third-party companies should not offer
delivery service without express written
consent
of the restaurant
i was moved to introduce house bill 593
when a constituent and downtown small
business owner
alex horton of cafe lorraine
shared her frustration on social media
last fall please note she wrote we do
not take orders on grubhub doordash
postmates or any delivery service if you
place an order through a third party
site we cannot see it and will not be
able to fill the order thank you for
your patience and please know that these
companies have listed us without our
permission end quote
according to an article dated february
24 2020 on manchester inklink several
other queen city restaurant tours
expressed similar frustration
uh including a co-owner of north end
bistro who said last year when we closed
for renovations on doordash
a door dash sorry when we closed for
renovations a doordash driver showed up
to pick up an order for items that
hadn't been on our menu since we first
opened
the thing is we didn't have an account
with them so we didn't have customer
information
all i could do was complain on the
doordash site and explain why we were
upset about it
uh becky shared another story she said
i had a driver show up 40 minutes late
with a delivery we ended up making new
food for that customer but we still got
a bad review
and when i reached out to ubereats they
said unless the customer contracted
contacted them they couldn't refund the
customer so
i had to do it we lost cost twice
plus we lost a potential customer
uh and one other
anecdote from that same article
was the owner of restoration cafe also
in manchester quoted as saying
uh in our case the
incorrect menu that was two years old
with incorrect pricing and items showing
on the menu were no longer carried plus
it was full of typos
it ends up making me look like an idiot
end quote
uh and just this past weekend i saw uh
on instagram
uh roots vegan cafe and juice bar in
dover they shared uh that it's come to
our attention that we've been added to
grubhub and or doordash
we didn't do this and we can't fulfill
these orders because we are only open on
select days for the time being our
apologies to everyone who has been
placing roots orders
through these third-party delivery
services we had no idea this was
happening until today
so
this is an urgent issue it's facing
small business owners who are under
enormous pressure due to the pandemic
bad online reviews can lead
directly to a decrease in orders which
can lead to a restaurant's closure
especially in these challenging and
uncertain economic times
so i urge you my colleagues to send
house bill 593 to the full house with
the unanimous recommendation of ought to
pass so that we can stand up for small
business owners across new hampshire who
are being taken advantage of by
out-of-state
tech companies
funded by venture capitalists in silicon
valley who will gladly turn a profit on
the backs of new hampshire's restaurant
owners even if it tarnishes their
reputation or puts a few out of business
in the process let's put power back in
the hands of small business owners to
make decisions that are right for their
restaurants
uh thank you and i welcome your
questions
[Music]
um okay uh representative herbert has a
question
uh thank you chairman
and
thank you matt for
that explanation my question is
are are you uh are many restaurants
uh taking i mean have their own
employees make a delivery and if and if
can they do that
uh
um
[Music]
if this if this bill passes would it
would that interfere in any way with the
restaurant
having an employee make the deliveries
thank you representative for the
question uh this bill would not
interfere with
a restaurant having their own employees
make
deliveries for their restaurant it you
know if a pizza place had
had uh employees making deliveries
uh
that's totally fine this is really just
representative burroughs
um thank you and thank you for taking my
question representative just a quick
question um my understanding is mostly
delivery services take on the on the
order of 30
of the of the bill
um so how does it work if they're you
know if they're taking these orders
unsolicited offline how does
how does the money get distributed in
that scenario are they so are they i
guess the question is are the
restaurants automatically forced to take
a 30 discount if they do it without a
contract
thanks for the question representative
uh
my understandings is that each of these
delivery services
uh have different arrangements
which is why it's important that
restaurants get
things in writing they need to know
exactly what the financial arrangement
is so i think they all look a little bit
different so i can't speak to them kind
of in a blanket
setting but i
i do think it's important that that
restaurant owners
know what they're getting themselves
into when they're contracting with a
third-party delivery service
any other questions
uh seeing none we thank you very much
for your testimony
chair we'll call on tom uh bauscher
who is in support of the bill mr chair
yes sorry
max had his hand out uh i'm sorry keith
had his hand up
okay there it is now okay sorry yes
keith you have a question for uh
representative wilhelm
uh yes i do thank you mr chair and thank
you for taking my question
can a restaurant refuse
to
provide service to one of these delivery
services
uh thank you representative for the
question i know that there are some
restaurant tours some small business
owners who are going to be testifying
that might be a good question for them
uh as i don't know
uh what that
that kind of user experience is like
from the the small business owner's
perspective
okay representative abramson has a
question
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um
so
is the the underlying problem that the
delivery services is mentioning your
business and advertising the fact that
they'll
that they'll uh make a delivery for your
restaurant without making a previous uh
or is it that
yeah why don't we why don't we like to
let let's have to tom bauscher uh if
that's okay with you uh representative
wilhelm let's let's have tom bauscher
answer these questions yeah that works
for me thank you chairman all right go
ahead tom why don't you um
make your presentation and you
roll in these questions appreciate it um
yeah i can answer all the questions that
the representatives have just outlined
my name is tom boucher
i'm the ceo and owner of great new
hampshire restaurants our restaurant
group
is is uh t-bones that's our mother ship
uh and then we have copper door and
cactus jacks and cj's great west grill
we employ almost a thousand people now
we just opened recently in concord i'm
sure many of you have driven by on 93.
um let me just let me just start out by
saying
um
to answer i can't remember i started to
write them down but to answer some of
your questions really quickly
these companies these third party
companies are not getting permission
from the restaurants as a matter of fact
uh
doordash
and grubhub both kept putting us up on
their websites
advertising using
our name
our product our brands our trademarks
and our menu without our permission and
we asked them at least a dozen times to
take take it down why because as
representative
uh william mentioned
they had the wrong menus they had the
wrong prices they were delivering late
and i'm telling you we hounded them
absolutely hounded them to stop putting
us on their website they were doing us
no favors even before the pandemic
as a matter of fact
i ended up having to sue them and you
can look it up on new hampshire business
review just google doordash
on new hampshire business review great
new hampshire restaurants and we won
they settled
because they knew they were wrong
these these national and even
international companies are coming into
our little state of new hampshire
robbing these mom-and-pop
uh locations
of
their profit
and believe me when i tell you
you know we're we're a big player and
we're fine
but
these other these other organizations
they can't afford this 30 fee
so to answer
uh another representative's question
if you contract with them you have the
choice to contract with them they will
charge you a marketing fee
an administrative fee
of course the meals and rentals fee
and the delivery fee
and the tip
so i went i played a dummy customer
yesterday and i went to backyard brewery
which is in
manchester i ordered their 16
cheeseburger
when all said and done it was twenty
backyard brewery is not making a penny
on that
restaurants make between three and five
cents of every dollar they take in
and during this pandemic
we're on the ropes
we're on the ropes and these people are
taking complete advantage
of these small restaurants
and it's it's disgusting to me to be
honest with you and i'm not i'm not
someone that wants to litigate i'm not
someone wants to create onerous
laws
but we need a law to outlaw these these
companies from
literally stealing money from
restaurants
during this time and quite frankly
forever
um all we're asking for is a law so that
other
small mom-and-pop
restaurants don't have to go through
what we went through we spent thousands
of dollars to litigate this we won
we didn't win a lot it barely covered
our our uh attorney fees
but you know what
we're off their sites and we're going to
be off their sites forever and if they
put us back on
they're they're in they're in for a
major lawsuit so
to end
i think that
by passing this law we're not asking
the state to enforce it what it does is
it creates
an avenue a very easy avenue for a
restaurant to say
stop putting me on your website
it's illegal here's the law here's the
statute
and then if it continues
they'll have a class action lawsuit from
thousands of restaurants
and then they'll stop
it's not right it's not right they
cannot use my brand my name my
trademarks to profit off of i have no
control once that food leaves my
building i have no control are they
opening the bag and eating french fries
yeah i've read that online
are they
are they delivering it on time not a lot
it's it's just it's it's just terrible
and i'm not willing to risk our 36-year
reputation on this on these third-party
companies
thank you
i'll take many questions okay
uh representative johnson has her hand
up
good morning and thank you for taking my
question
my question is do other states um like
in new england especially have similar
laws
are there
other precedents within the state and
other states
that this
wording and stuff for this bill has come
from
um well uh the answer is yes i'm not
sure about new england but i know
california recently passed it
and i i will tell you that
and i see some other restaurant tours on
here restaurants are struggling right
now i mean this is so hard this is a
heavy lift for them to get
get this up on the plate if they could
i'll bet
hundreds of restaurant tours would be on
this call right now and i'm fortunate
enough that i can
stand here and represent our company and
hopefully hundreds of others
it's
it's an impossible task for them to find
the time to bring it to all of you all
of your attention but the answer is yes
california recently passed the uh almost
the identical law
thank you
okay uh next up is representative
greeson
well thank you mr chairman and thank you
mr boucher for testifying this morning
had you received any demands for payment
for these uh marketing fees and such
like that from from any of these
companies you said that they were using
your logos and
uh trademarked materials and stuff menus
and such but had they actually sent you
any bills saying pay for these services
no but great question um
if you don't contract with them you're
not charged these fees however
they increase the prices
again i use the backyard
brewery as an example they have
contractually
agreed with them to pay these fees if
you don't so i went on tgi friday's
website did the same thing
their sixteen dollar cheeseburger came
to a fourteen dollars cheeseburger came
to twenty two dollars
so they charged the administrative fee
that the delivery fee the tip and the
meals and rentals tax
which is passed on completely to the
customer
so the customer thinks that tgi fridays
is charging 22 dollars they're not
it's doordash that's charging that
so it's complete it's it's it's so
deceptive
well said okay uh representative
abramson's next
thank you and thank you for taking my
question um same as before is it the the
source of the problem that the food
delivery platform
is is advertising uh your company and
using your brand name um i'm looking at
the bill and it says a food delivery
platform shall not arrange for the
delivery of an order from a food service
establishment
um
is your your concern with the fact that
they're advertising and using your brand
name correct
without my permission
okay thank you
all right uh representative meckler uh
uh thank you mr chair uh mr boucher
did you follow through on your uh your
brewery and on your uh
friday's
delivery in other words do you know how
much if you follow through that that the
brewery or uh thank goddess friday
actually got for their 14 and 16
hamburger
well they got they got
exactly what they would normally charge
i did not actually order it i just went
to the final phase of checkout they did
not
they they would get exactly what they
would normally charge in the restaurant
so they would get you know backyard
brewery would get their 16
not the 29 that i would have been
charged
okay
thank you mr chairman uh this could be
for either tom or matt
oh in section three
it says uh
the violation should be fined a hundred
dollars for each delivery
do you think that
amount of uh fine is sufficient
i think there just should be a law
stating you can't engage in third-party
delivery without their permission that's
that's the that's the bottom line to
this if restaurants want to engage with
these companies and be charged 25 to 30
god bless them they're losing money
every single day of the week
and i wish i i so wish some of these
restaurant tours would just do the math
you're not you're losing money every
single time if you're contracted with
these third-party deliveries you are
losing money they are not the life saver
that the media puts out there saying
restaurants are surviving on takeout and
delivery absolutely not it's it's we are
not surviving on that casual dining
pizza places sure that's their that's
their bread and butter that's what
they've been doing for
decades right but a casual dining
restaurant like copper door
uh
uh representative wilhelm did you want
to also respond
yeah thank you chairman i i just wanted
to say you know if if the committee
ultimately thinks that you know taking
out this
100 enforcement amending the bill uh
so that it it takes out that
language that's that works for me that's
totally fine i think tom is right i
think the
class action lawsuit is what ultimately
would bring
uh these third-party delivery services
to justice so uh you know having having
a specific dollar amount may not be you
know the teeth that we we actually
uh think that it might need it it might
be better to just strip it i think
that's what california didn't in there
bill
just be careful
yes representative yeah follow up
uh thank you uh matt
what my question was more in the line of
is a hundred dollars not enough of a
fine
not too much but not enough i mean five
hundred dollars
uh you know the hundred dollars is a
pittance to these companies 500 bucks a
shot
you say they do say they do 10 a day
it's 5 000 a day that might actually uh
you know flick their ear
thank you
uh i thank the representative for his
question and i uh invite the committee
to do what you will with this uh piece
of legislation if you feel like it needs
a you know a larger penalty i think
that's fine i also think you can take it
out again and and that class action
lawsuit will ultimately be the the
pressure that these third-party delivery
services need to do the right thing
thank you
okay thank you uh so i'll now invite uh
miss horton to testify
good
good morning thank you um so i'm alex
horton i own cafe loren it's a small
coffee shop in downtown manchester so if
i could just offer some insight into
what happens when you get one of these
deliveries that you didn't sign up for
so we were contracted with
we're contracted with a delivery service
through square the online
point of sale system that we use
and they actually have really good
delivery
fee prices it's like a dollar fifty in
order fine that's what we use
um
we
keep being listed on the grubhub website
we're not contracted with grubhub
but
people think we are so what happens is
someone a customer will go on
place an order on grubhub
and then as tom said a grubhub delivery
driver will show up at the cafe now
to work with one of these delivery
services you actually need a tablet from
them
or a sign in online like they'll give
you an account
with your sign in to see your orders
coming in so we have no way of
seeing and capturing those orders
so someone might place an order online
it goes through grubhub grubhub shows up
we don't have the food ready obviously
because we can't see the order we have
no indication that there's an order that
has been placed
and then
we can't refund the customer grubhub
refuses to refund the customer and
essentially it's it's like what do you
do in that situation as a small business
because
like tom said you're going to get a bad
review
because the customer never got their
food we do our best to call them and
explain the situation and tell them you
know you have to go through grubhub to
try to get your money back but grubhub
usually won't give you your money back
so essentially they're stealing money
from us they're stealing money from our
customers
and if you choose to contract with them
it is true they make you sign a document
that says we're going to take 30 percent
of every order which is more than the
fees that they take they're cutting into
your profit and it's just not worth it
so
if anyone has anything
under them yeah they contract if you do
sign a contract you're going to sign a
contract you don't want it sounds like
right
with ambulances
so
so the question i have is uh because i
uh we read an article in union leader in
and kingston pizza i guess it was and it
turned out to be fraud and that so when
they show up when when uber shows up to
or wherever grubhub shows up
they're using their credit card to pay
for
your
no no one um no one pays us
in other words so when they show up and
want to pick up an order
they just say that there's an online
order that's been placed
and you can say well too bad we don't
know anything about it don't worry
exactly because we can't see it there's
no way for us to know if they're a real
grub hug driver if they're oh right it
could be fragile right
well because well if if you don't have
the pad you don't have the order right
um
then but so i guess what happened in the
kingston was that they would turn around
and place the order
with a fraudulent credit card and that's
how those people got defrauded so i was
just wondering whether whether grubhub
or or these companies whether they're
paying you because i i never crossed my
mind that you actually would give them
the food without any money being
exchanged
right but some places do because they
don't want the bad review they think oh
we must have had a grubhub order or we
must have had a doordash order and to
kind of make things right with the
customer they might send out
food in which case you lose money on
that entire order
okay okay
okay uh representative bartlett has a
question
thanks very much mr chair and thank you
very much ms ordon for coming um to
speak with us mr boucher um
my question is this if we go to
amend this
it means that the bill gets
delayed
um
from what you're testifying
i have to
i mean the question is would you like to
see us move on this as quickly as
possible
yes if possible thank you thank you
there is there is a pandemic going on
that caused this
uh representative van hooten
how excuse me
thank you mr chair good morning ms
horton it's pleasure to see you here um
i maybe have more of a
rhetorical
question than a true question but it
just seems to me that this is a poor
business model for grubhub as well it
sounds as though they are taking a shot
uh in the public's eye as well as
probably a financial shot do you agree
with that
statement
i do but i think that they're big enough
that they don't care they're i mean
they're they're country-wide they don't
it doesn't matter to them if one small
cafe in manchester new hampshire
is having an issue with them
so thank you thank you
[Music]
representative hamm has a question
yes um i'm i'm just curious um
whether there's two ways um that these
delivery
uh companies um
work i've i've certainly been present
and
and part of the group that ordered um
go on the restaurant's website and you
pick out what you want and
and and the restaurant adds on the tax
and
and you add on a tip if you want
and then there's a delivery fee and you
get your food
now are there two ways that that these
delivery companies do business um
you know and this
observing this was in a larger a larger
area than you know the small towns in
new hampshire but but
isn't that one way you can use these
delivery services to enhance your
um
i'm not sure i understand the question
so are are you asking if i could
if i could delete it let me let me jump
in so represent him there's nothing
stopping any restaurant to have a known
food delivery system and you know
theoretically that's a good thing to do
but you know that takes resources and
and let's face it you know customers um
are lazy and
if they had a good experience with reits
or somebody in the past they've got that
app already on their phone so they're
gonna have to just go there first uh
rather than see gee i wonder whether
that restaurant actually has its own
delivery system or not and that's really
what the problem is is that people are
there's good marketing there and for
grubhub and everybody knows who they are
and so they have the app on their phone
so they're more apt to just default to
that without realizing that
the restaurant does not have an
arrangement nor does they want to have
an arrangement because they lose too
much to do to provide that service so so
it's a it's a quandary
i think that does that answer your
question
um yes but i you know i i was on the i
was under the impression some of these
deliveries
we got were
via a you know like um
uber or
or some other
some other delivery they they were not
employees of of the restaurant they were
a contracted
uh service exactly and that's what this
legislation is requiring
you're saying that that that if if uh if
grubhub wants to you know put that
restaurant on their web page they need
to have a contractual arrangement
and it's up to the two parties to figure
out how to make that work do i have that
right tom you got it
spot on
okay
what's up
all right is there any other questions
we're all set i assume your hands just
up on it because you still have it up um
otherwise uh i i don't have anybody else
signed up to speak
um this is always a little scary is
there anybody else who's participating
want to raise their hand uh
and and
introduce some new information if not
uh oops so we're all set okay so we'll
close the public hearing on uh house
bill
593 and
on the sheet we had eight people in
support
uh we had
six people opposed
and
um
that's what it is okay we'll close the
public hearing and the time being 9 34.
and
boy i lucked out on that one okay we'll
open up the next public hearing uh house
bill 65 requiring food service
establishments to establish food allergy
awareness procedure
otherwise known as rachel's law
okay so the sponsor rosemary there you
are rosemary i'm
i'm going to promote you
and tom and uh alex i'm going to demote
you
thank you very much appreciate the time
yes we can oh great thank you
it's nice to be back before commerce
committee
um and i come to you today to introduce
hb
65. um i sent all of you my written
testimony last night so
i'm pretty much gonna read most of it
not all of it
but this is a bill to require food
service establishments to adopt food
allergy awareness procedures
this bill is identical to hb 1102 which
passed this committee last year and
passed the house
it was stalled in the senate due to
delays brought on by covid
the requirement for restaurants to have
a certified food safety manager on site
already became effective this past
january first as part of the new
hampshire food code
food safety training includes food
allergy awareness
however this rule only applies to new
hampshire restaurants licensed by the
state
15 municipalities fall outside the state
jurisdiction but h.b 65 would extend
certification requirements to them as
well
these municipalities are bedford berlin
claremont concord dairy dover exeter
keene manchester merrimack nashua
plaistow portsmouth rochester and salem
boot establishments exempt via
the new hampshire dhsh rules would
remain would remain exempt
and there's there's a whole list of
exemptions
but some background i want to go over to
consider is this bill was inspired by
the death in 2019 of rachel hunger a 21
year old unh student who unknowingly
ingested an allergen at a new hampshire
restaurant the restaurant was unaware of
her allergy with this bill patrons would
be alerted to notify their food servers
of any food allergies and restaurant
workers would have the training to
respond appropriately
rachel was one of an estimated 32
million people affected by food
allergies in the u.s alone
and this is up to one in every 13
children and one in every 13 adults
the cost of food allergies is estimated
to be 24.8 billion dollars annually in
the us
six states already have passed
restaurant legislation and it it runs
the gamut
this bill is probably on the low end of
the regulatory responsibilities
but illinois maryland massachusetts
michigan rhode island virginia and a
couple
metropolitan areas have food
allergy awareness
i'm linking in my
written testimony i linked to a question
and answer sheet that dhhs put out to
answer questions about their regulation
so um
this bill is a sensible approach to
address the growth and danger of food
allergens while balancing the interests
of restaurants
so i ask all of you to please recommend
and ought to pass
for this bill thank you and i'll be
happy to answer any questions
yeah so uh i'm sorry i didn't have a
chance to read the bill i'm just reading
now did you you said that that the uh
the patron is required to notify the
establishment
yes though um this bill includes a
requirement that
wording beyond menu and menu boards that
if you have a food allergy to notify
your server
that when
hb 1102 was first conceived
mr chairman
i met with mike summers from the new
hampshire restaurant lodging association
and this bill is a result of a
discussion with him to help cover
restaurants liability and
so that they have to be aware i mean the
the training doesn't matter if they
aren't aware of the allergy
right right
so but it implied that the the patron
has to notify
yes but i i didn't actually see that in
the statute all i see is that uh it
requires the establishment to have a
sign
which assumes the consumer the patron is
seeing that sign
but uh that that they're supposed to
notify
yeah it's similar to the regulation we
have now that on menus it states if
you're having um undercooked meat or
seafood
you know there's some language on menus
i i was around i was around for writing
that sentence
and uh that was just a mandate that they
had to put that on the menus yes
okay but there was no
there was no mandate that the patron had
to
uh notify
the uh you know you know they're just
supposed to be aware of it and but that
there was no but so okay
i
belabored this enough okay so we do have
lots of questions and so uh
representative burroughs is first
thank you and thank you for taking um my
question representative wrong um
i'm i'm i
i guess my question is i i was trying to
figure out how big these restaurants
would be who are regulated under rsa 143
and so my question is is it i assume
some of these establishments may be
really small so my concern is is it
practical for them to have
the food protection manager there at all
hours if it's a small establishment and
i was wondering if you could speak to
that
well the food allergy risk is going to
happen depending on what food they serve
but this is really mirroring what's in
the new hampshire food code for
restaurants that are licensed by the
state
so they don't make an exception for
restaurants depending on their size
i just wanted to mirror what they have
so it applies to all new hampshire
restaurants not just those that are
licensed by the state
i think when patrons go to a restaurant
they're not
saying oh well this restaurant's
licensed by the state and this one isn't
i think this provides some consistency
in what the rules
already are on the books
follow-up please
further question me inquire yeah so
again in um you know this this seems
like very reasonable to me so i just
want to make that clear but my question
is let's just say there's a small
sandwich shop in concord and um
it's open after seven where they don't
get as much business um the manager is
not there after this after seven o'clock
is it practical to ask this small shop
to have this food protection manager
there at those hours
well i believe it is so because anybody
coming in and i think if you speak to
some of the people who suffer from food
allergies
i don't know it's
i think that they this this law would
ensure that there's some protection and
some awareness of the risk that they may
have consuming food there
so i i don't think it's unreasonable for
a restaurant to have this type of
training among their workers and at
least one of them would have to have it
for each shift
thank you
yeah so but uh would you clarify who
who's licensed by the state and who's
not and because you mentioned all those
cities so
those cities have their own regulatory
authority and so therefore do not
require the state license
yes well they have to license on their
own but they don't have to
mirror
the new hampshire food code most of them
do and they eventually will but
it's it's not a
an established
in statute that they have to follow the
new hampshire food code but typically
when a city updates their
their own local food code they mirror
what's in the state code and then the
state also mirrors what's in the federal
food code that's how this came to be it
came in through the u.s food code but if
i in my little podunka town range
which we don't have that regulation um
is every restaurant required to get the
state license
yes yeah they they've been in range
they've been required since january
first
january first it just wanted the fact
that they were required to have have
this person on duty okay but i'm in
merrimack and there may be restaurants
in merrimack that have that don't have
to comply with the january
city the big city that decided that they
were going to handle the licensure
themselves
absolutely okay representative bartlett
you muted and um thank you very much um
okay so i was pulling last year's bill
on this representative wrong and um i my
one of my questions is
we amended it does this
bill
include the amendment
um which was
yes
okay the bill in front of you is exactly
the bill that passed the house the
amendment that was made in committee was
to remove in fact actually i think the
i think i brought that amendment through
um it was after discussions with the
food protection
director of dhhs
part of that bill included a voluntary
program where restaurants could qualify
to be
considered allergy friendly but the
dhhs did not feel they had the resources
to manage that voluntary program so we
just took it out
and then there was an amendment made on
the floor of the house to rename it
rachel's law
but both of those amendments um are
captured in h.b 65. that's right um i've
got
the the amendment that passed i have
your other amendment i had an x through
it i thought i wasn't sure which was
first um
and it did come out of our committee
sixteen to four auto password amendment
um thank you for the work you've done on
this i know there are a lot of other
folks that want to want to speak to this
and we have a great deal of written
testimony
um and many of the restaurants are are
very much in favor of this so thanks for
bringing this forward again
okay yeah representative mcaleer
um thank you mr chair um
representative wrong i i looking at this
there seems to be
uh a number of
exceptions and that sort of bothers me
like roman numerals free uh does not
apply to any food services
establishment exempt from licensure and
then
under four number three exemption for
food service it seems like there's an
awful lot of exemptions here how any
idea how many restaurants are not
uh you know not under the state or under
the under the uh
the towns
and and couldn't this be amended to
cover those as well
well
i think
i don't know the number to be honest
with you the number of restaurants and
um i'm sure the food protection
director from the state would know that
um my goal with this is is twofold one
is to bring awareness of food allergies
not just of the the restaurant but also
of the patrons that they know that they
have a responsibility to notify their
server because so that the restaurant
can be uh can respond appropriately make
sure they're not being served something
that's going to yield a reaction and
make that person sick
as far as the exemptions go i just
wanted to mirror
what's in the state rules already
and not to have a laborious bill that
would
um where some restaurants would be uh in
compliance with the the bill but not be
in compliance with the state and vice
versa so i was really looking
prioritizing consistency
between
this bill and then how it's how it would
be enforced at the state
i don't that answers your question or
not but yeah it does thank you thank you
thank you
okay representative weston
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative rung for bringing us this
legislation i'm wondering if you could
give us an idea of how onerous the
training is uh who gives it what it
costs and how long it takes
yeah um i actually printed it out there
are um
the training can vary i know that i
think with the new hampshire restaurant
lodging association they've done it in
bulk like you can buy like 16
programs and and there's a discount for
it um right now there's there's six
organizations that offer it um in fact
from the state's q a it says in order to
obtain certification of a food
protection manager a person must pass a
food
safety certification examination
and be issued a certificate from the
following accredited certification
organizations or by a program developed
by one of these organizations recognized
by the conference for food protection so
there's there's six organizations that
offer this i went online and just did a
cursory search of most of them and um it
ranges from the exam as being 35 because
you don't have to take the test
but you can just take the test if you
pass that you get certification but the
the content's difficult they do
recommend you take the course
and most courses now i don't i couldn't
find any um
programs that are offered in classroom
those are the most expensive ones and
they're about 179 dollars a person but
most of them range anywhere from 50 to
um
you know 150 dollars
and like i said some restaurant
associations or large restaurant chains
will offer it as a group they'll get a
group discount
and then it's a oh and then to answer
your question if it wasn't in line uh in
okay representative greason
[Music]
now good morning uh representative and
thank you for uh taking our questions
this morning um
one potential issue that i can see here
is
um
which allergies is this manager
going to have to be prepared or these
managers going to be have to be prepared
to deal with and what happens if someone
has an allergy for which no one is
properly trained i mean it seems to me
like the peanut allergy uh if i
understand that this rachel uh
was allergic to peanuts and that may be
very common but what if there's
something else that just how do you
prepare for all the possible allergies
well we're not we're really this bill
just focuses in the training the
certification focuses i believe it's
like eight or nine major allergy groups
i knew them all last year it's like
wheat
milk
or dairy seafood nuts tree nuts hello
um
no it would only cover the major
allergens but those are actually um
most over 95 of food allergies fall into
those groups
someone having someone having a less
common allergy they would have to assume
the responsibility um solely for what
they would be ordering
all right thank you
but at the end of the day it's is it the
idea is that the restaurant knows what
are the ingredients of whatever they're
serving
so if the person mentions that
ingredient then then there's a problem
thank you mr chair thank you
representative wrong for taking my
question
um i've been in the food business and my
family has for many many years and i'm
aware of
safe serve and
the cities that are licensed by the
towns and
um the ones that are just licensed by
the state but um if
if um a restaurant um can promote that
they've had this training and an
individual comes in
um
they can't can they
feel safe
eating there if they have you know
allergies
to
you know nuts um
for instance there might be
you know there might be sourced foods um
from another venue that does have nuts
in it but it's not identified that
there's nuts in it so what kind of a
recourse does the restaurant have or the
patron have if
there's an issue
and they've been they have the
certification
um
i i don't know if i'm understanding your
question um but let me try to restate it
and let me and let me know if i've got
it so let's say if a restaurant is using
a product and they're not aware if it
contains an allergy but then they go on
and serve that to someone under right
oh okay
um
my understanding from federal law is
that
food coming in has to be labeled as
containing an allergy an allergen so the
restaurant would be aware of it because
if they're bringing it into their
restaurant it's got to be labeled that
it contains
um
you know an allergen
so for instance i'll give you an example
let's say um a restaurant is buying a
thickener or gravy
it would have to say that it contains
soy or or wheat
as they get it in
and the training would alert them also
as to
what things have an allergy an allergen
in it and what doesn't
because there's soy and a lot of food um
you know we think it's only in soy sauce
but it may be in other food but the
training alerts them to what type of
food has that allergy in it
and just a just a follow-up
yeah thank you um if an individual has
such serious you know allergies um isn't
it fire beware like just don't go out to
eat because there could be at any point
in time
you know so if someone does get
uh deathly ill
and the restaurant has gone through this
training
what happens then are there lawsuits
what's
there's not this bill doesn't
that doesn't um
forbid them it's not in a legislation
that would assign liability
but it's really to reduce the risk i
mean most allergens
allergic reaction um people get really
sick for about a week or two um the the
the cases where someone dies from an ana
from anaphylaxis
is very uncommon i think it's only like
maybe maybe up to 300 cases a year in
the us
but it's to reduce the incidence and
it's so prevalent i mean um it's like
one ever one out of let me see 32
million people in the u.s suffer for it
so
when you add up all those dollars of
lost productivity and people not being
able to work because they've been sick
this is really to reduce the risk of
sickness from an allergic reaction
all right thank you
okay uh
no having no more questions i'll invite
john dunn to testify
thank you thank you everyone
good morning uh thank you for the time
uh my name is john dunn
i am on the board of directors with the
new hampshire restaurant lodging
association uh mike summers was tied up
in another hearing so i'm here to
represent the
industry
i'm also the
director of operations for the michael
timothy's dining group and i'm also a
certified serv-safe uh instructor
just give you a little bit of background
of where i'm coming from
a couple concerns that the industry has
regarding the the build it it seems to
be a little duplicitive in the fact that
like you said the state is already
requiring the cert the food protection
manager certification
throughout the state
uh i would
like to know how many of the
self
governing towns
don't require because a lot of them are
more have always been more restrictive
than the state
i know portsmouth nashua merrimack all
require uh the certification
for someone on the staff to be certified
in uh
it's typically the serv safe
certification that most people get uh
which does cover the allergens
so that that's definitely a concern
where there might be some crossover some
changes to the state law may not
impact
you know crossover with the law here
just concerned about some
some crossover
issues there
the biggest concern we have though is
well actually the biggest concern we
have
is uh
getting someone sick
in the restaurant industry it's it's the
biggest fear that any restaurant
operator has
is that someone has an allergen and
you know something got missed along the
way
and someone you know has an allergic
reaction to food that we serve them it's
it's definitely a fear for anyone that's
in the restaurant business it's
something we we all take very seriously
uh and obviously you know
the impetus for this whole case is a
very tragic case
that no one ever wants to experience so
it's something that
the good operators
are very concerned about uh
you know
the other concern in the bill that we're
worried about is the
the word all uh including this message
on all menus there are so many
menus that go out in a restaurant and
you know just missing that this warning
label on one of the menus could cause
some some problems for the the
restaurant operators uh you know you've
got a
your main menu you've got a dinner menu
a cocktail menu a wine menu you might
have some specials you might have a
pop-up menu that comes up you know
remembering to add that onto each menu
can be owners to the operation uh
so there's definitely concern there and
there's also you know the concern that
it says uh you must inform your server
uh with the way things are changed now
that there's many different ways that
people get their orders into restaurants
there's digital menus
there are um
you went to the fast food restaurants
you could be ordering from a kiosk you
can't communicate that to your your your
server as it be
um and also with the third party the
hearing just before i was talking about
grubhub doordash they have menus online
are we responsible for making sure that
they're posting this on on their sites
now so i think there's there's
definitely some concerns in there uh
of some
areas that where
restaurants can end up with more
liability due to this legislation uh you
know it's being you know
the conversation last year with mike
summers was making sure that it was it's
upon the consumer
to
notify the restaurant that they have an
allergen
so
happy to answer any questions on any of
this
these statements but
those are the concerns from from the
industry if you could help address some
of those areas in this legislation would
okay representative abramson has a
question
thank you mr chair and uh thank you mr
dunn for taking my question uh sorry my
voice is a little bit uh
uh hoarse you said that uh most of the
restaurants already um use servsafe and
and
doesn't serve safe i've i've
taken the servsafe
uh certification
uh before don't they have a whole
section on uh allergens
food allergens
yes they do they covered uh some mention
of the big eight peanuts tree nuts milk
eggs fish shellfish soy and wheat are
the big eight they're
encompassed of the allergens but i can
tell you from working in the business
there's there's thousands of other ones
out there uh you know cinnamon garlic i
had a lady once it's uh had an allergy
to perfume so no one else in the room
could have perfume it's like how do i
accommodate this guest
you know we ended up having them come in
early and we had them in a separate area
and able to accommodate that guest uh
but yes it is part of the surfsafe
training uh
you know it's it is just getting rolled
out and with covid there's a lot of been
challenges with getting people certified
so i think there's been a little bit of
grace period on getting people certified
um obviously there is an expense to it
uh the servsafe
just the exam alone is fifty dollars per
per employee
uh
you know if you and if you just go take
if you think you can just go take the
test
it's not very likely they're gonna pass
the test it is a very encompassing uh
exam it's not just something you can
just walk in and just oh i've been
working the business for a long time and
i can take this and pass it
uh it's not that simple
follow-up
for the question you may inquire
um so do you think that this uh this
bill would it would expand the uh
allergen training to additional
restaurants in the state
or is is is that already being done
it's it's already a part of the uh the
serve safe uh
you know
i think that's a big step right now for
new hampshire is getting restaurants um
with a food protection manager on
on-site uh
you know the
someone else raised the question about
should it be someone on site at all
times
that's going to be a tough challenge
especially for the small operators
and a lot of times some of these places
have you know young younger staff that
are already going to school
they're receiving training in-house from
that certified manager
when they're the person in charge that
you know that's part of their their
training is they're getting the training
from the food protection manager it's
part of the responsibility of the food
protection manager for the business to
make sure that the people in charge
understand and know
how important uh you know obviously food
safety and also the the allergen piece
of it is
all right thank you
representative bartlett
thanks very much mr chair um
i have two questions one is um when mr
uh done when you signed up you said you
were neutral on this but it doesn't
sound like you're neutral is that
correct
uh
i'm not going to say very allergen
information it's something that's very
important
so we're not opposed to bill we're
opposed to some of the language in the
bill
oh
okay so it wasn't just me
i i
i'm just looking for a clarification
yeah
i understand
did i click
[Music]
you're coming back you're sort of there
you might want to turn your video off
and just be just
oh
just turn it just lock you for a minute
yeah so yeah you're frozen
you're frozen here but if you turn your
uh video off that maybe your
your bandwidth can handle it
are you still there
oops
oh he turned off the video he's on the
bottom here yeah he's still there yeah
so you still there john
[Music]
uh what i'm going to do is i'm going to
bring some oh you there
uh he's not there
oh there he is okay i'm up in the lakes
region in the middle of an ice storm
here so
yes apologize
uh so um so i was looking for it was it
was a clarification it's a yes or no
you're you know if we pass the bill as
it is
are you opposed to it or are you in
favor of it i think it needs some
amendments in there to clarify a few few
items
okay um my follow-up mr
very much um
now this
this bill is only to cover
those
um restaurants that are
not licensed through the state but are
licensed through
local municipality
correct so this is not um
this does not change the state
requirements
um
mr dunn so
if it mirrors the state requirements
and you're not likely to change the
state requirements
what
why is there a problem with this bill
well the two concerns are
one being
you've got a separate
you're setting separate policy for the
self-governing towns so that i believe
there's led
through right now for the state
uh food code
where it's not gonna require
a
to be on site at all times it's that
there's a food protection manager
conflict between the the two where this
would be more restrictive than the
estate one would be should that
bill pass
uh the
other concern is including it on all
menus as i said there's there's numerous
is ordered uh
trying to cover all menus or it could be
you know
a statement listed
or
you know
at the entrance to the facility
the signage
the door you know no shirt
analogy
okay thank you right so i guess john
just sort of what she's asking is is
these two issues that you're bringing up
the all on all menus and full-time
person on duty is that not in the state
statute
well the allergen is not in the state
step
i really missed that one the allergen
this food allergy where is not in the
state statute just the
the maybe we'll hear from dhhs yeah okay
so what i'm going to ask you john is you
know if you want to just i would turn
everything off reboot you know hopefully
maybe that'll solve the problem and then
i'll invite someone else up to speak so
the next
person i have
um
is heather uh
heather gass
promoter panelist
oh jan smith i should have had jan oh
sorry
jan but uh
all right
can you hear me i just want that to sell
okay so what why don't we hold you on
let's let uh miss gas speak and then
we'll come back to you sure
sure um so thank you chairman hunt and
thank you to the committee my name is
heather gass i'm a resident of merrimack
new hampshire lifelong
new hampshire resident and i am
testifying today in favor of hb65
um please refer to my mitten written
testimony that i emailed to the
committee for additional facts and some
data sources and in light of the time
today i'm going to try to keep this to
under three minutes for you
appreciate it
so i have a severe allergy allergy to
tree nuts my two-year-old son also has
multiple life-threatening food allergies
so this bill is really important to my
family and i because of a near fatal
reaction that i experienced at a nashua
restaurant
i ordered a meal that i had eaten at
least a dozen times before at the same
restaurant and this time it contained my
allergen
i soon went into anaphylaxis and we
found out that the kitchen had made a
substitution that was not um anywhere
that we knew about and
the dish now had contained my allergen
my throat started to close um i
struggled to breathe
my fingers turned blue my lips turned
blue and my oxygen levels were quickly
dropping
um i was rushed to the er where they
gave me epinephrine and steroids
and thankfully i recovered but i tell
you this anecdote because i want to be
very clear
i almost lost my life because of what i
was served at this restaurant
and this isn't just a small problem and
i think there's many shades of gray in
between here between experiencing
anaphylaxis and just having an itchy
mouth or a key throat i just want the
committee to understand that there are
very varying degrees of allergic
reactions that can happen
um and so according to research
conducted by mckinsey and company last
year more than 32 million americans do
suffer from life-threatening food
allergies for new hampshire that means
that's more than 131 000 of us
just like my son and i
um supporting this bill doesn't only
make sense from a health standpoint but
from an economic one research conducted
by the national restaurant association
in 2012 found that during normal times
restaurants lose approximately 45
million dollars per week and potential
sales to food allergy families who don't
feel safe dining out at places that
don't accommodate them
this means that critical revenue goes
elsewhere like to neighboring
massachusetts where there's already a
law that's very similar to hb65
those dollars could have potentially
been spent here in new hampshire if we
had a better policy of informing
customers about potential allergens and
making sure that staff are trained on
how to keep customers safe
now new hampshire does have a small
number of allergy friendly
establishments such as 110 grill
sub-zero ice cream and burton's grill
who have all implemented training and
safety protocols to accommodate
customers with food allergies
and these establishments benefit from
their allergy pilots policies and
training by preventing harm to their
clientele and gaining the loyal
patronage of families like mine in the
food allergy community
so with other states like our neighbors
in massachusetts and rhode island and i
think there's about four others that
have already enacted similar laws there
are already ample resources that are
available for implementing the
requirements of this bill
thank you again for hearing my testimony
today i will hope that you will
expeditiously expeditiously recommend
and not to pass on hb65 to help keep
families like mine safe when dining out
in new hampshire and i'm happy to answer
any questions that you may have
thank you
any questions from the committees
um
ms gas a quick question
is there a sort of a universal antidote
for
these type of
reactions at all
and is that something that you would
carry with yourself or a restaurant
might have that's a great question so
currently in the state of new hampshire
there is no
law requiring that restaurants have to
stock epinephrine which is the go-to
medication for an allergic reaction
people that have a diagnosed allergy
typically will have a prescription for
an epipen and are recommended to carry
that with them at all times
that's not to say that mistakes happen
and sometimes they get left at home
you know depending on the the patient
they have different recommendations for
medications to take but epinephrine is
the gold standard i'd also like to
mention that um food food allergy
reactions do happen to people that don't
have a history of an allergic reaction
so that's an instance where they
wouldn't have epinephrine available and
but they they wouldn't be able to form
the restaurant they have it if they
didn't know they had that allergy yes
that is a possibility yes
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
if you go to massachusetts and you go to
a restaurant that you have you know
frequented and you do have a reaction
what happens then
i mean how do you
yeah
sorry that is a great question i think
i'll speak on my personal experience
when i go to a place that um has that
training and when i when i tell them
about my allergy and i know that they
note it down they go and check with the
kitchen to make sure that everything's
still safe for me them doing those steps
gives me confidence that my meal is
going to be safe
and i do realize that mistakes do happen
and if you know as a result of something
like that if i did have a reaction
personally i would not hold that
restaurant responsible if they had taken
those steps
um on the other hand i've been at plenty
of restaurants where um i mentioned that
i have an allergy and um i've even been
served for example a salad with pecans
on it which could have sent me into
straight amphloxis even um having told
them about that but that's for a
restaurant that doesn't have some sort
of allergy policy in place so i think
just in short to answer your question i
feel more confident when they have those
policies in place and when i can see
that they've they're actively following
them when i go and make my order and i
see how the process is going so that i
can trust that my food is safe
thank you
okay thank you
um having no more questions we thank you
very much for your testimony thank you
so i'm sorry jan i didn't see your name
you didn't sign up
sorry
my fault uh good morning
thank you chairman hunt and honorable
members of the committee for the record
my name is jan schmidt and i represent
ward 1 in nashua and that's the last
formal thing i'm going to say i only am
here to support this bill strongly i
know that's terribly important
at one time heather gass was a
constituent of mine and it was very
important that we bring
bills like this forward to protect her
and her family
representative rung has already answered
all the questions that i would have so i
will give my time up and say thank you
very much for your consideration of this
great bill bye bye everybody
thank you very much
okay john done sorry we'll try try again
you're assuming you're on with your cell
phone
yes i am hopefully this is a better
connection for you
okay so do you remember where you left
off
uh i'm not sure
okay so i guess the question was is to
be sure that uh
the committee would want to have comfort
that that we're not doing anything
different
than what is already in the state statue
which i guess is called the food safe
statute uh rule i guess it's a rule it
was done by rural brother statute and
we're just worried that the two things
you brought up which was the menus and
the full-time personnel on duty
is that in the uh the food safe
rules
it it it is in the fruit safety rules uh
that there is a certified food
protection manager on duty
it is not a regulation under the food
code to post on the menu that the
customer must inform you of an allergy
okay so you still have this requirement
that somebody has to be on duty at all
times who knows what to do when someone
says they have an allergy
what your concern is then would be is
that the menu
that might be the one that got put under
my car window at the at the supermarket
that supported yeah or
you've got a chalkboard special and you
write a special up on a chalkboard and
now you're gonna add this disclaimer at
the bottom of that menu as well it's
like when you say all menus
all is a very encompassing word you know
on the main menu on the or post signage
posted within the facility on a table
tent on a brochure uh i mean
the other
warning that's out there regarding
consuming raw undercooked foods may
increase the the possibility of a
foodborne illness
that requirement doesn't say it needs to
be on all menus
that
the language on that can be posted on a
sign in the restaurant it can be on a
table tent um you know when it's on them
when you
have a menu you put an asterisk next to
the item that
such as raw oysters you would asterisk
it as that is an item that is you know
served raw
whereas the allergens you can't really
do that because every single menu item
could could potentially have an allergen
so
um you know having
you know having the communication that
the the guest must please inform us of
it of any allergens uh on your main menu
signage within the restaurant but but
requiring on on every single menu that
you produce uh
opens up some doors for some liability
to restaurants right so if i understand
you correctly so for instance if you
were to take out an ad in a newspaper
and it happened to lift your menu
then you would that that small print if
you shrunk the menu down to fit on that
ad now that small print could be so
small that you could barely see it if at
all and that could be problematic
and so you you don't happen to know what
the language is in the state rule is or
how do they how do they say that do they
say
i mean because i remember when we wrote
it about the seafood that it had to be
on the it had to be on the menu
but i don't remember if we used the word
yeah i'm i'm referring back to the food
code on that
yeah because the food code requires it
to be you know noted on on the menu if
you have items that are
served raw or undercooked
right that that can also be posted
in the facility
okay
representative abel has a question
go ahead rich yes thank you um i'm not
sure if this is for you mr dunn or
perhaps or uh representative wrong
but
um
i did not see any penalty
on the bill
if
you if a restaurant had
uh
a menu that didn't didn't include this
and i don't recall there being one from
last year
so
i would think that um
well would it be would it be correct
then that
that
uh
you would be excused if you happen if if
if it happened not to be on all menus or
something i mean it just this seems like
a
i just want to ask that question
it's more about liability
when
a case occurs
uh
you know that the person who's who's
affected by it will come back and say
well the state law says it's supposed to
be on all menus you didn't put on that
that menu and to tell me that i should
have told you so it
it's more of a liability concern it's
not a you know i'm not concerned about
fines or anything of that nature it's
do you want to attempt to answer that
question
rosary yes thank you um in the uh state
rules there is a 250 dollar fine for
non-compliance that says it's possible
so it's at the direction of the
department but i do want to tell the
committee that the language regarding
that would be required to be on menus
actually was a suggestion by mike
summers when i met with him on this over
a year ago
he felt that restaurants needed to cover
their liability because they couldn't be
expected to protect someone from
allergic reaction if they didn't know
they had the allergy so there were so
when we had a meeting
he suggested having information on the
menu so that the restaurant could be
aware and then and then make any
i hope that answers your question
okay good
is there uh anyone else who has a
mr dunn seeing none we thank you very
much
and thank you attendees i have one more
one hand up
and i'm so michelle
tawan me taiwani
good morning thank you so much for
allowing me to speak and um
uh thank you to ms rong for bringing
this forward i'm michelle tawani and i
live in concord
um and i am in full support of house
bill 65.
according to the journal of allergy and
clinical immunology anaphylaxis is a
life-threatening allergic reaction is
common in the us more than one in 13
people
in america have experienced
anaphylactics
my daughter hope tauwani is a freshman
at plymouth state and she is one of
those one in 13 americans
she is allergic to tree nuts
cashews almonds hazelnuts
walnuts and bee can't pecans or just to
name a few
um you'd think it just you know if she
just didn't eat
nuts in general she'd be fine but the
problem is that they can be found in
breads pizza crusts french fries a fria
later on a food prep area and even food
prep equipment and more
um
and not only can um
they be found in those items but
they're also make could be processed in
a facility that did have tree nuts an
allergic reaction could happen so going
to eat at a restaurant
is like playing russian roulette um
there's such inconsistency in knowledge
food safe uh food practices
menu items and what ingredients are in
each item in the restaurant industry
spans the gamut of having no idea to
truly understanding the severity of food
allergies
my daughter hope has had four instances
where she has told her server about the
allergy and
those three those four places have
served items with nuts in them hope is
fastidious when it comes to sharing her
food allergy every single time she
places an order
two instances occurred at popular coffee
establishments uh she was served a
hazelnut coffee even though she asked
for a regular coffee and because she is
fastidious about her allergy she read
the label on her cup before she drank it
same thing happened at another um
ordering coffee at a different place um
it was served with almond milk and again
she didn't drink it um she read the the
marking on the outside of the cup prior
to say taking a sip thank god um
so
it's not just about whether or not the
person shares their allergy which
absolutely that is definitely a critical
component to all of this but it's also
about the knowledge on the other end
when someone is actually sharing their
allergy
um
and she's actually even had to inform
you know when she orders coffee please
don't use the same spoon that you use
when you serve coffees with um
with almond milk in it um because she
knows the person on the other end
receiving the order has not been trained
or don't doesn't quite understand
because they say you're ordering coffee
there's no nuts and coffee
um another restaurant she had gone to
she informed her server um
and they have a practice where the
manager actually delivers the food to
the person with the allergy um and he
actually brought the salad
from the kitchen put it in front of her
had a special flag on it identifying
that it was allergen free and it was
covered in pecans
he literally walked it from the kitchen
to right in front of her and didn't even
notice there were pecans all over it
and the last most scary instance
happened at dairy queen she knows she
can't typically go to a traditional ice
cream location because they share scoops
in between each ice cream container
um but she always felt safe going to
dairy queen because the ice cream comes
out of machine and she was assured it
was clean so after having a few bites of
her ice cream even though she informed
the server she actually had a tree nut
allergy that person actually wrote it
down and actually gave it to the person
preparing it
um
she felt like something was wrong with
her throat it was closing i actually
ended up having to give her an her
epipen
and it kept getting worse and so i
called 9-1-1 i gave her a second
injection of epipen
and drove to concord hospital
and i knew i could get there faster than
when an ambulance could arrive um and
because i was on the phone with 9-1-1
they alerted the hospital that we were
on our way and literally when we walked
in the the lobby was filled with people
waiting to be uh taken in but they took
her first because they knew the severity
of anaphylactics
so those are just a few instances of
cross-contamination um and the last
being the worst and truly not necessary
if their staff were trained
but i can share with you also dozens of
times that we've actually either left a
restaurant
because the server was flippant and not
knowledgeable about food allergies
hearing statements like you should be
fine
yes i don't think that has nuts in it
you should it's okay
this is life or death we can't have
shoulds and you you know you could be
fine um and so literally we just get up
and leave and someone had mentioned like
what about when you order online
and this is just our family we never
order online we always call because we
never know who's going to be reading the
order on the other end of um the
computer even if we identify there are
food allergies and this is what it is so
we call we talk to a human we hear the
voice um
and place our order
um there's such inconsistency across the
platform of restaurants and food allergy
awareness let's get these restaurants
informed of the severity of food
allergies to make it safer for all to
dine out i recommend
and opt this to pass this is life or
death for approximately one in thirteen
people in new hampshire
okay any uh questions for
mr tulane none thank you very much for
your testimony
uh i have one more person uh marcy
kozlowski
how did i do with that
uh would like to testify go ahead marcy
okay you did a pretty good job
kasinowski is the last thing yeah
thank you members of the committee for
having us here today i am speaking in
support of house bill 65
rachel's law
when we first introduced the version of
this bill in 2020
i was full of
emotion and mourning
for our babysitter and friend rachel
hunger we miss her every day
and we will continue to spread her light
in any way that we possibly can
what i've learned
over the last year
is that the emotions that we continue to
feel grief anger sadness with the loss
of rachel will not bring her back
it's time for us to take a stance on
this real issue and that's why i sit
here before you all today to ask the
members of this committee to pass
house bill 65 requiring food
establishments to have allergy awareness
procedures
i feel it's important to share that i do
not have a food allergy
no one in my family has a food allergy
growing up i cannot remember remember
anyone specifically suffering from a
food allergy
i can imagine that many people would
share in these same statements
and therefore may think that food
allergies are not a
big deal
i can absolutely admit that i was naive
to how big of an issue this really was
i could share numerous numerous facts
today that i found from credible online
sources with you regarding food
allergies the number of people it
affects how many trips the emergency
room each day each minute are due to an
allergic reaction from a food allergy
the percentage of children who admit to
being bullied because of their food
allergy
and how it makes them different from
other people in their class but i assume
and you all have heard today numerous
facts already so instead i'd like to
paint you a picture
you are a mother
or father of a child with a severe food
allergy you've kept them safe their
whole life
you check labels on everything you held
them out of summer camps because you
can't control the environment once
they're there
you're a master chef at home because
dining out with your family is simply
too risky
and you trained them to disclose their
allergies whenever they are out and to
avoid certain establishments
you've put in the work
now they're headed off to college
but they're ready you've done everything
that you can do to prepare them to
handle life in the real world with a
food allergy
and i imagine this story is similar to
that of the hunger family
but it only takes one exposure
it only takes one instance where
something was not prepared properly or
without an educated staff
for all of that work that you've done to
be wiped away
one in 13 adults and children suffer
from food allergies as you've heard
from other people this morning
but imagine if that one in 13 was your
son your daughter your sister your
brother or your friend
for us
rachel was that one person
and though we can't get her back my hope
is that this committee will see the need
to pass house bill 65
and require food service establishments
to do their part in preventing another
life from being taken too soon
we hope that you the committee members
will stand with us today
so those suffering from food allergies
no longer have to dine in fear that
their next bite could be their last
breath
thank you
very elegant description of the problem
um
uh representative abramson has a
question if you're willing to entertain
one
yes all right
thank you mr chair i'm having some
technical problems with uh raising my
hand for the last witness um but
my question is
um
would this bill as written have
prevented uh rachel's death
if it had been in place or would it at
least reduce the uh the chance of her
loss
i believe that it would have reduced the
chances
of her loss um
obviously rachel was
very aware of her allergy and
disclosed that in many cases um
i can't say whether or not it would have
prevented it and i don't think that is
the
ultimate goal of this
but in order
i believe the
the idea behind it is to give people
more
um
more of a sense of
safety
when dining out in food establishments
follow-up
further question and inquiry
uh would you be amenable to an amendment
that
that attempted to accomplish the same
thing make sure that all of our
food preparers and food handlers
um have additional uh
allergy training food allergy training
i would be in support of that
all right thank you
thank you
hey
thank you so um as usual happens when i
say there's only one left there's a
bunch more people signed up now these
people most of these people did sign up
ahead of time so i do feel somewhat uh
required to put them up but i can ask
all of you who are coming in is that
please not repeat what's already been
said um you are cutting into palestine
tableware so maybe you might hear about
that issue um so and i have a lot of
people signed up for that bill uh which
i'll tell them the same thing which is
please do not repeat yourself if you can
offer up something new that'd be great
so we'll start with nicole caruso
and i will promote you nicole
hi thank you so much for having me
um i'm here
to speak on a personal note um so this
will be a little different than i think
what you guys have heard
um i was a transfer student with rachel
i'm currently a senior at unh and i had
the honor of being her roommate
um for that first year we had together
and
we
shared a very small square of a room
together and
that became very difficult once she was
in her coma
i moved my mattress and all of my things
into the living room of our apartment
because it was just too hard to
be in that room with her pictures
everywhere and um
i you know i got really used to hearing
her toes and her ankles crack as she'd
walk through our apartment
and she always claimed it was because of
she did leave behind her cat scurry as
well
with us and
rachel
had always talked about
[Music]
her future
and how she really wanted children and
she couldn't wait to help the world when
she graduated
and she always spoke about wanting to
reach a large demographic of people
rather than making an impact on a
smaller scale she wanted to work on a
larger scale
and that's a huge reason that i'm
supporting this law rachel's law is i
think that she would obviously
absolutely love it but i think it's a
great way to honor her in a way
that she would have loved because it was
something that she had always wanted to
gain in the life that she
had and unfortunately lost too soon
because of something that i feel could
i am also a person who has allergies
like rachel and i have been very shaken
by this tragedy not only losing somebody
but realizing how life-threatening
allergies can be on a more personal
level
um
i think this bill is so important not
only to me but to the unh community and
the medical community that never got to
see rachel's braid ideas that she would
have brought to the world
and of course for the hungers who lost
their daughter in a way that no one
would ever wish
and
rachel just deserved more than the time
she was given
and i think this law is a great step in
the right direction to make sure that no
family has to go through what the
hungers have gone through
and i think
that that's kind of shown
as people have spoken about you know the
1 in 13 people that do have allergies
and i think
it does need to be taken more seriously
especially
you know after
losing someone who meant a lot to you
and someone i considered one of my first
friends when i transferred to the
university of new hampshire
um
and
i think that's that's all i have to say
i apologize for my stuttering i was just
a little nervous to speak but i am able
to answer any questions if anybody has
well thank you for sharing it was very
important to hear thank you
uh
next is
colleen smith who
hello thank you
chairman hunt and members of the
committee for the record my name is
colleen smith i'm the administrator of
the food protection section within dhhs
and i'm here just to let you know that
i'm
available to answer any questions that
you may have with regard to current food
safety regulations in new hampshire
well the big question we're having right
now is is this this totally mere the one
that is the state regulation yes um and
and i guess the question was one was did
the state regulations say all menus
and boards
and
um and then the idea that there's a
full-time person on duty
so um i'll answer the first question
with regard to the menu board so with
with regard to
the menu advisory that is required for
our undercooked foods that
their the statement is
brochures deli case or menu advisories
label statements table tens plate
placards or other effective written
means
that sounds like all
okay
so i
yeah yeah so i i certainly um are uh i'm
aware that this that this bill proposes
rulemaking requirements so it is
possible that we could um
clarify
the menu board aspect in rule or if
there was additional language
in this the statute
that would that would work as well to
further define out menu or menu boards
okay great and then the full-time person
on duty there's somebody on duty at all
times
so
so currently uh the
the new hampshire rules for the sanitary
production and distribution of food has
incorporated the fda food code the 2017
version into its regulation and so that
requires the person in charge to be a
certified food protection manager and as
was mentioned in previous testimony that
certified food protection manager
training does include allergy
food allergy recognition awareness of
symptoms and the expectation is is that
that person in charge transfers that
knowledge to food other food employees
under his or her supervision during that
their shift as their duties relate to
food allergen awareness so there are a
few types of establishments that are
currently exempt from the requirement
and those are those that
don't have food proper minimal or
or no food preparation so examples would
be
like a dollar store that might be have a
food license because they sell milk and
eggs but they don't have food
preparation or
a a seller of meat
a farm stand that's just selling meat
and poultry in a refrigerator or
freezer
scenario those currently do not have to
have that certified food protection
manager training so
um other food establishments do
currently have that requirement
um if
hopefully that answers your questions
but happy to take any follow-up okay i
think that that's it
all right well thank you very much um
any other questions
from miss smith uh c9 we thank you very
much for your testimony
hi how's it going
good can you guys hear me yes we can
oops
oh i did that that was me that was my
bad
i hit the wrong button
uh oh
they've done a bozo no no maybe we
should maybe she can reconnect and we
can tell yeah she's gonna have to
reconnect uh i can't believe i did
things pictures moved on me and that's
how i get that good okay so uh deborah
middleton
you're you're on so you can speak
my name is deidre middleton
although i am not a
new hampshire resident i'm here today
in support of passing the house bill 65
rachel's law
in october of 2019
shortly after rachel had passed away i
was at breakfast with my family members
and my seven-year-old nephew has tree
nut allergies the first thing i stated
to the waitress was that we have a tree
nut allergy pointing to my nephew she
replied
no problem the only thing we have are
pecans and they are separated from the
other foods
not even five minutes later she brings
three containers of syrup for the
pancakes my nephew ordered
we are all talking and kale is reading
the container labels and i hear him say
pecan
i picked up the syrup containers and
approached the waitress pointing out the
pecan syrup and explaining
cross-contamination with food allergies
can be fatal to people i know she did
not do this intentionally and it seems
like an innocent mistake to some to some
people but not to a person living with a
food allergy
having a designated restaurant employee
trained regarding food allergies can
prevent things like this
happening in restaurants it will save
lives
we can't put a dollar amount on
someone's life
and they deserve the right to enjoy a
meal out
it's too late to help rachel but this
bill could make a difference so other
friends and family members do not have
to suffer the loss of a loved one
make a difference be the miracle and
pass house bill 65 and i'm open for any
questions
not seeing any thank you very much for
your testimony
okay kendra try again i promise i won't
throw you off
um i hope everyone has a warm mug of
something and some warm socks on in the
heater this morning because it is quite
chilly here in new hampshire my name is
kendra middleton and i am in favor of
house bill 65
rachel hunger was my best friend um
and on march 19th we went out to eat at
a restaurant that we frequented
all the time on campus in durham she
consistently had the same order and one
time we go out to eat and there was
cross-contamination and after two
epipens as you guys know the reaction
wound up being fatal the scariest part
about allergies is that everyone's can
change every few years
with more and more food becoming
processed on different equipment due to
keep up with demand of the population
allergies are becoming more and more
prominent and more and more severe
with more allergies coming up the amount
of people affected is going to continue
to grow especially here in new hampshire
this past october after 24 years of life
i found out that i have a deadly food
allergy
too artificial dye 24 years of life i
had survived without having a reaction
and one night at home with my roommates
had i arrived to the hospital five
minutes later i would have been rachel
and i promise you that after my
experience i know what anaphylaxis looks
like and thank god that i did because it
quite literally saved my life even
though i couldn't save hers
food allergy stats from the american
academy of allergy and asthma and
immunology
food allergies affect eight percent of
adults six percent of children zero to
two nine percent three to five eight
percent six to thirteen and eight and a
half percent between 14 and 18 and 38.7
of reactions are severe even if never
having one before and 30.4 percent of
people have multiple food allergies and
numbers are getting worse like i said
due to population and demands of food
why are restaurants important in this
equation
one it's unrealistic for people to never
go out to eat i travel for a living and
i can tell you that if i didn't have the
option to go to restaurants i wouldn't
be able to do my job and keep a roof
over my head
two with an allergy to dies alone i
never know if i can even have pasta
sauce or edamame out at a restaurant and
i don't think it's outrageous to ask
people to understand what they are
putting on the table in front of people
three sometimes not always but you have
a waitress who doesn't seem to care
doesn't know or doesn't really want to
find out what they are putting in front
of you and that is fatal
fourth this is a minimal cost to
restaurants and like my mother said you
can't really put a dollar sign on
people's lives
and lastly this is life or death
and it's not something that is
likely to grow out of you know when
you're a kid you think people are going
to grow out of peanut allergies but it's
more likely that someone is going to
grow into an allergy
and this could prevent not an another 21
year old from
dying literally anyone so today you have
the opportunity to be on the right side
of history to save lives and to change
the amount of your population that is
affected by this and children that are
affected by this you are put in these
seats to positively positively impact
your community and today i hope you
choose to positively impact your
all right thank you
we do have a question if you're willing
to entertain one
representative abramson has a question
uh thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um do you happen to
know of durham is one of the towns
that's uh exempt from state requirements
because they use a their own process
um i am not sure i would assume not
because this was a restaurant that
before we had informed her of her
allergy and she continued to order the
same menu items which is why on this
particular occasion she did not inform
them because they were things that she
had ordered on menus before
follow-up
for the question main choir
and uh would you also be open to
an amendment to the bill
that attempts to accomplish the same
thing
um yes i would as someone who suffers
with food allergies i i think it's
important to pass this because it
affects not only adults but children and
not only new hampshire but everywhere
all right thank you very much
okay well thank you very much thank you
and again i apologize for throwing you
off that's okay i'm used to it
okay uh spencer
con conveni
hi there
hi
uh my name is spencer company and i'm a
senior at the university of new
hampshire i personally never knew rachel
but her experiences deeply resonated
with me
after hearing rachel's story i knew i
had to share my two in the effort to
help i have both a raw egg allergy and
nut allergy and these are both
anaphylactic
my first weekend as a freshman at unh i
went to
get dinner at one of the dining halls
after one
bite into a piece of shrimp cooked at
the stir-fry bar i knew i instantly was
in trouble
thankfully due to quick action i was
able to get help
from an emt before going into
anaphylaxis
i went to the dining hall knowing my
allergies knowing how anaphylaxis works
knowing how to assess food for risk but
due to improper cleaning and knowledge
of cross-contamination by a staff member
i left the dining hall on my first
weekend of college headed into an
ambulance
on a saturday afternoon i headed to
downtown durham to get food with my
girlfriend
after back and forth of me explaining my
allergies to the server the restaurant
decided that they could not serve me
they let me let me say that again i was
explaining my allergy to the server i
was leaving my anaphylactic allergy to
the server who did not understand my
common egg allergy
all i asked was that my food be cooked
on a separate and clean surface which is
common food allergy protocol
on a different day i headed to
portsmouth to get food with a group of
friends
i did my part in telling the server my
allergies like i do every single time
after them coming back to my table to
ask exactly what my allergy was three
times
they brought our table's food out but
mine did not come they had the manager
come over and explain that he did not
know enough about the allergy to cook my
meal safely i asked myself as i watched
my friends enjoy their meal in front of
me
how does the manager of a large
restaurant know not know enough about a
major allergy which was egg to refuse to
serve a customer
therefore staff members need to be
educated and trained
simple education can lead to
improvements for customers experiences
this common feeling this is a common
feeling
for people with allergies
and if this continues this will there
will be another story of someone losing
their life
simple training of staff to understand
common allergies will help prevent out
reactions
and will save lives my friend and
classmate in high school lost her life
to an allergy reaction rachel also lost
her life as well i'm here to share my
story
of a different perspective of being
refused to be served but also here to
help save lives from allergy reactions
thank you for your time
thank you
that's quite a big egg egg's got to be a
nightmare
what do you use to replace eggs with
nothing there's not much to replace
can't make mayonnaise without eggs
oh my god i'm sorry
all right uh i will now call up
[Applause]
yeah go ahead bar
yep hi there can you hear me yes
okay so my name is barb higgins i live
here in concord
i um met jen hunger rachel's mom because
i lost a daughter as well not to food
allergies but to a death that was
completely preventable so preventable
death for young people is important to
me
but i'm going to speak to you today as
as somebody who understands to some
extent the political process of making
change i'm on a school board in concord
so any any of you know the last couple
years in the concord school district
have been horrifying um we've had
horrible things happen in our district
that affect young people sitting on a
board an elected board being challenged
with the task of keeping children safe
is is a huge responsibility so i'm going
to ask all of you as legislators here
to take out the details of what food
allergies do on tuesday versus friday
and how different is an egg allergy to a
peanut allergy
um those things aren't the issue in this
bill here
anytime we have a tragedy um society
does the right thing and looks at what
can we do to change the outcome for
future families
what killed my molly shouldn't have to
kill other people what killed rachel
shouldn't have to kill other people
um i'm old i'm 57 so in the early 80s i
was a cocktail waitress and that was a
time when everybody drank lots of
alcohol everywhere
my dad put it in his car driving to the
golf course it was a very very different
time
and then we had mothers against drunk
driving and we had
a nationwide drinking age of 21 and if
you all will recall that that change was
met with a lot of pushback people didn't
want to change change isn't easy change
can be difficult and uncomfortable
but to those moms and dads who lost
children to drunk driving it was
imperative that we as a culture make a
change and we did and now we don't think
twice about things
local bars don't overserve patrons
anymore because they realize there's a
liability to them
the next thing that comes to mind for me
is when we were redoing main street on
downtown all the hubbub and the talk
about how to make all of our stores
handicapped accessible sure i have two
legs that work so what do i care if
there's a ramp or not well how lucky am
i that my legs work but to someone who's
confined to a chair and wants to have a
donut or a bagel or buy a book getting
into the store is incredibly important
so as a school board member looking at
policies around hiring educators around
holding educators accountable for
appropriate behavior around making sure
they're teaching in a way that services
all students and not just those that are
lucky enough to learn in a normal way
we i spend hours and hours pondering the
children that are different
so all of all of the details of this
bill we could go round and round for
hours it's too specific it's not
specific enough can we put stickers on
every menu what about if you call online
absolutely these are things to consider
but they have nothing to do with passing
this bill knowledge is power we take a
step for rachel
and and somebody else's rachel is going
to benefit from that
um
obviously i'm in huge support of this
bill i i relate as the mother of a child
in heaven i relate as a board member who
works really hard to protect children um
and i represent someone that
if i had a lobster it would be very very
ugly um so so i have it all i'll end
with an experience that my daughter
gracie had um on christmas eve she had a
muffin and according to the ingredients
of the muffins she's not allergic to any
of them but she ended up epipendant at
the er the owner of the bakery small
concord establishment said to me
i never lose a sale on an item without
nuts i can't tell you the number of
muffins i haven't sold have nuts in them
so i do feel this type of education and
legislation will improve service at
restaurants and improve revenue
because again we don't we don't lose
money um on on allergy free foods and
products
so i would encourage you to pass this
bill um take take that
checking off every little detail hat and
put on the common sense hat
and know that educating and training our
restaurant staff will only be a good
thing
seeing your questions we thank you very
much thank you um i see jennifer hunger
hi
welcome back to the car i'm on my
daughter's computer so bear with me for
a second okay
i don't know how to operate this one um
hi
honestly i just really want to address a
couple of things i want to say that
i have six days between finding out that
this committee was meeting over this
bill and and this morning
and you can see the amount of people
that i was able to connect with who feel
so strongly about this that they wanted
to speak
um
the amount of people i could get if i
had more than six days would be daunting
there's there's
if this issue affects one in 13 people
then imagine the amount of people that
it touches that don't have the allergy
that just care about that one in 13
person if you don't have that person
you know i'm grateful for you
um but
you know i no longer have that person so
this i can go to a restaurant and not
necessarily think about food allergies
like i used to
but the amount of people who've reached
out to me in the last six days in
support of this and told shared their
story with me
just made me remember
all of those other people's rachel's
that
might be helped with this bill
um
it's not
i don't want i i don't want this bill to
be seen as something that is putting a
burden on a restaurant
i think that the idea that the person
with the allergy is suddenly going to be
able to go out and dine and feel safe is
we never feel safe all we would hope is
that there would be some sort of
collaboration between the staff at the
restaurant and the person with the
allergy to do the best that they could
to prevent
um you know a tragedy from happening
does it eliminate risk of course not
um and the person who's taking the risk
i can assure you knows that they're
taking a risk
but the expectation that maybe the rest
of the community could support them in
making an educated decision about what
they're eating and make them feel like
maybe the risk is a little bit smaller
is all that we're hoping for
the only other thing i want to say is
that epipens
and epinephrine
is touted as like the the thing that's
going to just just epi just eat it and
if there's if it had it then you just
epipen my daughter had two epipens and
the ambulance made it in three minutes
to unh
and that was not enough so epinephrine
is great and it has saved a lot of
people it didn't it doesn't always it
doesn't necessarily always save you so
um
that just speaks to the seriousness of
of the food allergies and that it there
is no vaccine there is no cure there is
no anything and these people you know
this is their daily life every day that
they eat something
they're at risk so if this could just
lessen the risk that that's our hope
thank you
so glad you you got on thank you thank
you
uh
seeing no questions we thank you again
thank you
okay uh barbara
okay so uh now
i have two more left
i have
hi
good morning
just thank you all for
being here listening to everybody's
different opinions i for one am
absolutely in favor of house bill uh 65
rachel's law i was a friend of rachel's
lucky enough to say that
um pretty much here today i just want to
say that to me this law
is just a way to ensure that people that
want to go out and have a bite to eat at
a restaurant can do exactly that they
can just have the night be
a nice
outing eating what they want doing what
they want because people with allergies
are gonna do what they need to do to
make themselves feel better
but they shouldn't have to do
everything by themselves the burden
shouldn't just be on them people that
are serving food should be aware of what
is put in that food and what is being
put on that table to someone that
doesn't just dislike something but it
can in fact change or even end their
lives someone like myself who's worked
in a restaurant i've seen firsthand that
not everybody serving food running knows
every item on the menu let alone every
single ingredient and
personally i believe that that needs to
change because it's not just about like
or dislike it's literally a matter of
life and death and like so many have
said before
it's not always realistic to say just
don't go out to eat because
some people like kendra travel for a
living or some people
just enjoy going out to eat and that
shouldn't be something that's completely
off the table
and i just gonna keep it short and sweet
i'm in full full support of this and
much love to the hunger family always
one person left
and
jody
go ahead go ahead johnny yeah oh you've
muted and unmuted yourself so
you're still muted judy i'm sorry about
that i had a little technical difficulty
um thank you for listening to me and i'm
in full support of hb65 i tried to edit
my um
my uh talking points as best i can um
try going to just read through it and
hopefully not repeat too many things
for sake of time
i became aware of the danger of food
allergy the day i nearly killed my son
at the age of 22 months
i gave him a peanut butter cracker and
within seconds his body reacted
face and eyes swollen like a boxer who
is on the losing end of 11 rounds
vomiting and lethargy and his little
voice saying help me mama
that was the day i understood how lethal
food can be my son's allergies told me
it's likely a next reaction would be
worse
we eat out at establishments and trust
that employees and management of these
establishments understand what food
allergies are to minimize our risk
sometimes we hit the jackpot with
restaurants like t-bones
the servers kitchen staff and management
are all very educated on food allergy
and take it very seriously we are
confident that these people are using
the same care and making themselves
aware of the ingredients in their food
how it was pre-prepared in an outside
facility prior to reaching their
establishment
how they prepare the food in their
kitchen and how it is served to prevent
cross-contamination
just like i do every single time before
a food item goes into my son's mouth
we have also stopped at food
establishments and when made aware of my
son's peanut and trina allergies
we are
we are made acutely aware we are a
nuisance and told well that food doesn't
have nuts and we have walked out without
eating
we cannot trust our son's life to an
establishment like that generally i
think it's not so much a lack of care
but rather a lack of understanding
many people think that as long as we
have the epipen we are fine if he starts
to swell up just jab him
the reality of the epipen is
that it's just buying your time to get
to the hospital
and just like rachel it's not a cure and
it's not a guarantee that it will save
my child's life
this legislation is crucial to implement
along with other food handling education
a food protection manager
would be an employee who would be the
allergy expert on duty
crucial to understanding and
communicating
according to
foodallergy.org childhood
hospitalizations for food allergies
tripled between the late 1990s and mid
2000s and unfortunately allergies aren't
going away
due to our diligence and the responsible
actions of the restaurants we frequent
and by the grace of god our son has
never had another anaphylactic reaction
but the reality is that my son could be
just one french toast sirloin steak
macaroni and cheese order from serious
injury illness or the worst nightmare
for any parent of a child with
anaphylaxis
death therefore i implore you to please
let rachel's life mean something great
and protect other anaphylactic food
allergy
thank you
um seeing no more questions i guess
we're all set thank you very much uh
i have no more hands up so i will close
the public hearing
uh we had
252 people and sent a response in
support
uh seven opposed and two are neutral and
with that we'll close the public hearing
and move on to our last bill
[Music]
house bill
618 relative to the sale and
distribution of polystream food service
products
so i would ask those who are going to
speak on this bill to please raise your
hand
and
go get my
okay
all right dude i'm gonna
and
representative spring
welcome back to the commerce committee
ready
have i
i don't see myself representative hunt
uh well that's true we can't see you
either you have to turn your video on
there it is
yes
no you turned it off
oh no you're no you just moved oh yeah
these screens moving around on me okay
okay well as they say in the interest of
time out of an abundance of caution
i will try to keep this brief i also we
also have a lot of people who have a lot
more information than i think is
that you need to hear from me so i will
try to introduce this bill
as briefly as possible i sent the
testimony to
to the committee i thought last night
but commerce apparently has two m's in
it so i had to try again this morning
so you should have my testimony
you've probably heard by the way
this is
a duplication of house bill 1564
which was passed by this committee last
last session and passed by the house and
it suffered the
tabling by the uh by the senate as many
of our good bills have
you've probably heard that you should
never heat up food or beverage in a
styrofoam cup because there are toxins
that will be released in the food
but we buy hot beverages and prepared
food and these containers routinely
after all that's the principal reason
why we use styrofoam is it retains heat
and cold
styrene is the toxin that styrofoam is
made from and it has been found to leach
into food
foam cups lose weight each time they're
used as we ingest the styrene
volatile styrene monomers are found in
the shells of eggs that are stored for
two weeks in polystyrene containers and
dishes cooked with these eggs contain
seven times more ethyl benzene as
styrene than those that are packed in
other containers such as cardboard
the manufacturer of polystyrene is the
fifth largest creator of hazardous waste
both liquid and solid
now
one of the things that got me very
interested in this is that the fact that
styrofoam products comprise an offensive
amount of litter that we're seeing along
roadways
and um i spend a lot of time on the sea
and on the beaches and floating in
masses
on the ocean
completely unnecessary
others who testify will tell you about
the widespread use
widespread styrofoam debris that happens
when it breaks up into smaller pieces
and gets either wind or water carried
and it causes cancer and digestive
problems for wildlife
there's no way to get rid of it
it can't be readily composted it can't
be right recycled and if it burned it
releases 57 chemical byproducts this
probably doesn't surprise you
in 2017 new york city released its
determination on the recyclability
of food service foam
in summary it said for 30 years attempts
to recycle food service foam both
subsidized and non-subsidized attempts
have failed at each step of the
recycling process the municipalities and
programs at dsny research tell a very
clear story and i'm still quoting
food service foam is not capable of
being recycled in an environmentally
effective or an economically feasible
manner
again to quote from this report the
municipalities found that food service
foam compacts and collection trucks
breaks into bits and becomes covered in
food residue making it worthless when it
arrived at a recycling
facility
and contaminating other other recycled
materials as well
it blows throughout the
material recovery facility missed by
manual sorters mistakenly moves with the
paper material and contaminates other
valuable recycling streams namely paper
which can be our most valuable commodity
in a recycling program
food service foam is too costly to clean
and process compared to the virgin
material and that comes from the 2017
stores and food service businesses are
already using paper products to replace
styrofoam thank goodness we can get
coffee where the it actually tastes good
it's doable we need to pass this
legislation to take a first very
achievable step toward eliminating
polystyrene from new hampshire
and beyond i would be happy to answer
questions about the mechanics of the
bill
great we do have questions
and we'll start with uh representative
burrows
yes and thank you for taking my question
um you might have started to touch on
this when my phone started ringing so if
i missed it i apologize i'm wondering if
there are eco-friendly alternatives to
the um to the styrofoam and how do they
compare price-wise
there absolutely are i think that we've
already seen it when you buy uh coffee
now you're very unlikely to get it in
styrofoam you're more likely to get it
in paper products
i actually contacted a
a country store that exports a good deal
of its material so i bought some cheese
from them and it was sent out
and
and it needed to be kept cold and i said
surely
you need to use styrofoam for this and
they said we wouldn't think of it
we use
shredded cardboard products
so it's entirely doable
styrofoam is like many things it's
it's very um it's very cheap
the hydrocarbon industry is anxious to
to make it because it is
uh it uses up uh
hydrocarbons that they are anxious to
find new
new
but the
the impact and i think other people will
talk to you about
about what happens when it gets into our
environment
and how much it costs to clean it up
shows that there is
a bigger financial issue issue than just
the cost of that cup
to the manufacturer
i hope that answers your question thank
okay uh representative uh fargo is next
yes thank you mr chairman um and thank
you representative spang could you speak
to the exemptions in the bill
um and and explain why these exemptions
are here
yes the exemptions
which you'll notice is the factory
sealed
packaged shelf stable foods
and uncooked meat fish and poultry and
seafood
are our health issues we want to make
sure that we're able to particularly
with the uncooked
meat fish and poultry it is a good way
to make sure that what is leaving the
the factory is indeed getting to the
stores
in a sanitary way
so it was felt that that needed to be an
exemption for the time being until we
can find some other way to do that
also
a little
the little country store that i was
talking to said well sometimes we get
things that are come to us packaged in
styrene
um and what are we supposed to do about
that and is it okay for us to uh to
accept these
and it seemed that if it's we we can do
what we want to control what's happening
to styrene within our own borders to
start
and hopefully
that will be spreading and i know it is
spreading um there are probably five
states that have already been
polystyrene food containers and
more than just food containers
thank you thank you representative
abramson
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um so apparently polystyrene is uh if
you heat it up too much
it can release chemicals into the food
is one of the problems i've noticed um
is it a problem for for cold foods i
know when i go to my uh
volunteered at the local uh
community table
that uh they used polystyrene containers
a lot for to go
items when they had recycle you know
when they had leftover foods and whatnot
those are usually uh cold or cooled down
um is that a problem for
for lower temperature
foods
thanks for your question uh
representative abramson
i think that
the finding that eggs stored in
styrofoam containers probably answer
that question
i was able to cite some statistics about
how much
how many toxins migrate from the eggs
into the polystyrene even though they're
kept
chilled
but of course
i don't know
i was i was raised to never put a
styrofoam container in the microwave for
example
but the cold is something that was
new to me too representative
all right thank you very much
thank you mr chair um
would you believe that
some of us have stopped frequenting
restaurants that will um use
polystyrene for takeout johnson's dairy
bar won't change their position in a
number of other restaurants and we
choose not to go there anymore
i would believe that
thanks for your question
those are the questions we like
okay thank you very much uh for your
testimony it's always a pleasure seeing
you jesus thank you the feeling is
mutual
so uh i will now ask
uh
christiana
dublin
to
there you go
you run oh you you just booted your
immunity yeah sorry it said that it
wasn't connected to my computer audio oh
there you go
good morning chairman hunt and
distinguished committee members my name
is christina dubin i'm a resident of
portsmouth a car seat school graduate
student and a volunteer with surf rider
foundation's new hampshire chapter i'm
speaking today in support of house bill
expanded polystyrene foam is toxic to
produce and its chemical components bio
accumulate once they're in the body due
to either food contamination or
economics eps food wear is not recycled
and it easily fragments into tiny
lightweight pieces impossible to contain
and non-biodegradable
all of this adds up to a high social
cost that is currently not factored in
therefore we see that eps containers are
cheap and thrown out after just a single
use
new hampshire would not be alone in
taking action on this public and
environmental health threat as rep
excuse me representative spang noted
five other states have passed or enacted
legislation banning the use of
polystyrene foam food wear even in the
face of this ongoing pandemic
i'm proud to say that portsmouth my city
of residence has joined many
other municipalities throughout the
country by enacting a polystyrene foam
foodware ban as of this past december
31st 2020.
and as a customer of portsmouth
restaurants and cafes over the past
eight years i've personally witnessed
that those that choose not to use
polystyrene enjoy a high degree of
patronage
specifically because of their choice to
implement other alternatives
new hampshire's landfills are nearing
capacity both tipping and transport fees
increasingly weigh on municipal budgets
the need for source reduction has never
been greater and it aptly sits at the
top of our state's waste management
hierarchy
section 2 of 149-m states that the
general court declares its concern that
there are environmental and economic
issues pertaining to the disposal of
solid waste and landfills and
incinerators
it is important to reserve landfill and
incinerator capacity for solid waste
which cannot be reduced reused recycled
or composted
so on under 149-m municipalities are
currently allowed to regulate solid
waste without explicitly laboriously or
needlessly listing every waste item
polystyrene is an item we can reduce
where any net impact is offset both by
societal and waste disposal costs
i think that this is a small common
sense in the right direction and i very
much appreciate your time and
consideration to favorably vote this
bill out of committee thank you
thank you very much uh we do have a
question uh representative abramson has
a question
uh thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
i was just thinking i i live in seabrook
and we're right on the border and about
half of our food delivery from the last
bill previous bill
half of our food delivery comes in from
north shore mass and about half of it
comes from businesses in new hampshire
i'm wondering if this bill is meant is
meant to have an
impact on food delivery what happens if
you have businesses restaurants from out
of state trying to make a delivery
and they put their food in a polystyrene
container
um i am going to actually defer to rep
representative spang on that one um i
from my understanding it's um
you know from takeout from businesses
that are in state that are offering
um that are packaging it rather
for transport from that restaurant
follow-up
for the question main choir
okay okay well i guess for whoever wants
to take it wouldn't that put new
hampshire businesses new hampshire
restaurants especially at a
disadvantage since it won't it might
only apply to businesses in new
hampshire and not
maine vermont or massachusetts could
they i would note here that maine um
you know it although you could say other
states you know it's a matter of time
this is happening um in surrounding
states so
i would say in the build there is a
section three uh this section shall not
prohibit a person from reusing
polystyrene packaging received from
products distributed from out of state
okay thank you very much for your
testimony uh the chair will change a
little
uh let's go
to the
those who are opposed to the bill
and i'm now calling up
good morning good morn good morning can
you hear me yes we can
excellent well good morning chairman
hunt and members of the committee my
name is omar terry i'm with the american
chemistry council and i am here to
respectfully oppose hb628
um as you all know especially when it
comes to restaurants this is a terrible
absolutely terrible time to be
considering banning polystyrene foam
food service
restaurants need every opportunity they
can to continue to stay alive and that
includes with food service where
both polystyrene foam as well as
alternatives
so restaurants are holding on for dear
life and every cent counts and
it is an extremely affordable option
that continues to help restaurants in
but you know there are people that are
really concerned with um diversion from
the
um
the landfills and recycling and so there
are new advanced recycling technologies
that are coming online to address
polystyrene foam food service as well as
plastics in general
it's an umbrella term called advanced
recycling but basically this technology
is able to take a polystyrene foam food
service where and separate out the
contaminants from like your general
sauce chicken in your polystyrene foam
clam shell
and then turn that clam shell back into
a new clamshell to be utilized again so
this technology not only recycles the
product but it also acts as a diversion
technology to help out with landfill
space
um there are examples around the country
where this is taking place one is uh in
oregon by a company called agilex which
is utilizing this when it comes to
polystyrene foam cups at
music venues as well as all other types
of food service throughout the state
ineo style revolutions is a company that
is building a polystyrene recycling
plant in illinois that will be recycling
100 tons of polystyrene a day once it's
operational
and then another example is in georgia
where
a company called nexus fuels is taking
polystyrene as well as additional
plastics and turning that into fuels and
waxes and shipping that off to shell
chemicals so that they can utilize um
this new
um you know polystyrene foam as well as
other
fuels that are coming from the feedstock
so that they can divert from taking
virgin material so it's making that
closed loop that we're looking for
i would like to point out that there are
several states that have already passed
advanced recycling technology
bills uh to you know make sure this
technology is seen as manufacturing uh
most recently pennsylvania passed this
law last year
in addition to pennsylvania
florida wisconsin georgia iowa tennessee
texas ohio and illinois have also passed
bills that would be pushing forward and
we would love to have something in the
northeast uh possibly in new hampshire
as well um i want to keep this brief i
know you guys have had a lot of uh
incoming and we'll continue to do so so
with that i'll open it up to questions
okay we do have several questions
representative burroughs from the
inquiry
yes um thank you mr o'terry for taking
my question um and that is that the um
department of health and human services
listed
um the the styrofoam is a carcinogen
as carcinogenic and that hot foods can
start a breakdown i'm causing some
toxins to be released into the
bloodstream is that a concern of yours
okay so that's a that's a two-part
question if i can you know take the time
to to answer that um first when it comes
to the possible carcinogen um
there is a study out from irk um
in europe that is that moved it from a
possible carcinogen to a probable
carcinogen um
one of the issues with the study is that
iarc only uses a
what's called a um
hazard assessment as opposed to a
two-step process which also incorporates
an exposure assessment most health
uh most health departments around the
world utilize that two-step process of
not only is something considered a
hazard but at what point is it a hazard
and that's called exposure
and the reason why professionals do that
represented burroughs is because
for example with water water
is technically drinking too much water
is technically a hazard for the human
body so if you only stay with a hazard
assessment um almost anything can kill
you right but the critical piece is at a
risk assessment at what point does a
substance become a
concern
and for exposure
and the information that is currently
out in the field we don't have a risk
assessment on that level for styrene in
addition to that
i do know that there is a organization
called the styrene
information research center they are
conducting a study and looking into the
science of that to answer that very
question because the information that we
have thus far over the past several
years is just inclusive
it is not appropriate for anyone to say
yes or no on this topic we do not have
enough information and so circ the
styrene information research center is
uh
taking steps in order to find some of
that information out
to the second part of your question
i think it's very important for members
of the committee to understand that
styrene itself which is totally separate
from polystyrene foam which we drink out
of styrene monomer is a naturally
occurring substance you will intake
styrene every time you eat a strawberry
every time you eat steak or beef or have
cinnamon
it is a naturally occurring substance
and so
uh when you have people that are going
to testify that say that there's a
migration between polystyrene and the
body
they might have had a strawberry that
day that would impact those results
right and so it's very important to
understand that polystyrene foam is an
inert
um
it's an inert substance
like very very little if anything is
going to be passing between you
and that cup
and the evidence that we do have which
is called a migration study suggests
that it is
well far below any threshold that you
would be getting from eating naturally
occurring food
did that answer your question
um
it did didn't give me a warm and fuzzy
feeling but thank you
okay
now thank you mr chairman and uh thank
you mr terry uh
the question are you familiar with the
process of photo degradation and if so
could you explain it
uh very broadly representative gretchen
so i will um
in the very broadest of terms photo
degradation is basically
how does a substance break down when it
is in sunlight
and you know how quickly does it break
down and um you know
how
how quickly how fast and you know
how efficient does it break down in in
sunlight um there was a store a study by
the woods hole
i think it's woods often there's a study
from a massachusetts institute the woods
hole
institute that suggested that
in sunlight polystyrene foam
specifically broke down a lot faster
than
otherwise known and so what i would do
is i will forward uh that information to
the committee so that you all have that
information um and they're still doing
some research but the the research that
that came out of the study suggested
that
under that photo breakdown basically it
was going to break down much much faster
than otherwise known or you know
previously understood
but that's my general understanding i'm
definitely not a an expert on it
thank you that's all
okay representative abramson
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um i keep thinking of
the example of the uh the hot coffee in
a polystyrene
cup they use polystyrene sometimes as
kind of a
like a thermos like an insulator
do you happen to know what the
temperature is where uh polystyrene
starts releasing chemicals into the
beverage
so i'll have to get back to you on that
representative um
because polystyrene isn't inert
uh
it's an inert material it's not supposed
to be releasing chemicals to you at all
um and so there's
i want to make sure to drive home the
fact that styrene monitor the substance
that polystyrene foam is made from and
the polystyrene foam cup that you're
drinking out of they are
totally separate they are as separate as
sugar is from wood right both sugar and
wood have cellulose but they're a
different form
and they do different things and so it's
very critical to understand that
a warm cup a warm coffee and a
polystyrene foam cup
is not going to transfer
styrene into your body
if anything it would be if you've had
some cinnamon into the coffee the
cinnamon in the coffee might be the
styrene that might be the trigger to
have any type of migration from uh you
know the cup to you but the pie starting
from cup it's an inert material um the
migration is not going to really occur
at a measurable level that would
impact your health
there are studies on that migration that
are there but to your specific question
about at what temperature
i'll have to get back to you
as to that on the migration study
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um once again could you give me the name
of the
group that you represent
the american chemistry council
all right and um and who do you
represent
so i represent the plastic food service
packaging group within the american
chemistry council so our members are
plastic converters and resin producers
okay thank you
you're welcome
all right seeing uh no more questions
for mr terry thank you very much for
your testimony thank you all for your
time and i hope you stay warm yeah thank
you
okay chair we'll call up john swan
okay you just have to unmute yourself
good afternoon everyone thank you for
hearing my testimony today my name is
john swann i come from dalton new
hampshire up in the north
country and i am the founder of save
forest lake
uh it's a group um
we're in the midst of a landfill battle
up in the north country
and that's the perspective i bring you
today relative to
my support for house bill 618
we've been involved in this landfill
battle to to save force lake and forest
lake state park from an encroaching
landfill
for the past two years and i can tell
you that
um
polystyrene foam
is
a product that
goes straight to the landfills it's not
being recycled
um and if you're familiar with the the
the waste hierarchy landfilling is
obviously at the very bottom of the
waste hierarchy
so i support house bill 618 and i ask
you two as well because this is a step
in the right direction the state of new
hampshire needs to get serious about
our solid waste policies i don't know if
you're aware but the solid waste plan
for the state has not been updated since
2003 and the state has failed miserably
relative to those waste reduction and
waste diversion goals
so i feel that
obviously as a member of society and
someone involved in this type of fight
we need to get serious about reducing
the amount of waste we generate
as a society so i feel that house bill
618 is a step in the right direction
it's a product it involves a product
that goes straight to the landfill and
of course if you if you're like me and
you like to take walks
you're going to find
styrofoam cups littering the the
landscape our scenic landscape so
um and i will say this if anything does
come out of this hearing
i hope those of you
who use single-use convenient disposable
cups will get away from that and start
using
reusable
hot and cold cups
i mean think about it we all have to do
our part to reduce what we waste as a
society so i ask you to please support
house bill 618 as ought to pass thank
thank you and for those of us who listen
to public radio we just heard about that
conservation law foundation's uh lawsuit
so we all heard about that 2003.
not going to go away yes
cena we thank you very much for your
testimony thank you very much and last
but not least i have bruce berkey who i
good morning mr church
yep
good morning
it can be seen and heard i hope and it's
still morning good yes great hi
well i'm i'm not sitting in for henry um
i am uh here this morning on behalf of a
company called techniplex
they own a subsidiary called delco
packaging
and dolco packaging is the leading
manufacturer of polystyrene foam egg
cartons in the united states
they manufacture foam poultry and meat
processor trays food service trays apple
trays
and pear trays
as well as other custom packaging
solutions
i'm here today to
echo um some of representative spang's
comments and certainly
the actions taken by the legislature
last year relative to house bill 1564.
1564 was a very similar bill
that we worked with representative uh
balch on former representative bulge
um he was the prime sponsor of 1564 and
he agreed with us that eggs
should be included in the
language of the bill and that is how the
bill passed the house last year before
being tabled in the senate
we're suggesting a couple of amendments
this year uh one for eggs
and one for
um raw produce
in correspondence that i sent to you i
sent a letter from mr george bradden who
is with delco packaging
and on the re or second page or reverse
side of a page if you printed it out it
would have the proposed amendment that
we uh are suggesting for the bill
but uh
you know raw eggs raw meat raw produce
they there's a
pretty complex supply chain as they move
into your supermarkets um
throughout the throughout the state of
new hampshire
um they're often packed in large
centralized facilities for reasons of
cost and food safety
um
and
you know in in
we're asking that eggs be included
because while
representative spang's bill does have
language in there addressing materials
this language that we're adding for just
eggs in general it would treat all egg
and produce production similarly
if we did not add that then any
production within new hampshire
would would be
disadvantaged
versus those
shipping eggs or produce into the state
um
we sympathize with the concern over
solid waste and environmental impacts of
litter they're important issues for
all of our municipalities and throughout
the state
but polystyrene foam egg cartons
trays for various types of meat and
apple flats are not normally found in
i know i never have and i would imagine
that most people that do not buy a
carton of eggs and eat the eggs on their
way home and toss the carton out the
window
so
to to adhere to interstate commerce
regulations
um
we're asking for these amendments we
think that they're reasonable they're
this house passed last year
and if the bill is to move forward we
would urge you to include that language
i'd be happy to try and address any
questions uh certainly there have been
some technical ones that i know i won't
be able to answer but i would endeavor
to
find answers for you so thank you very
much mr chairman and members of the
committee thank you representative
um thank you for taking my question um
i'm thinking about my local grocery
store they have quite a few items that
come in
um obviously
eggs and whatnot that are brought in
that that come in polystyrene
containers
but that you also have businesses that
have some of their food products
that are prepared maybe over the line in
massachusetts and then sent up to stores
in
new hampshire are those businesses going
to have to take every single food item
from the polystyrene container and
transfer them over handling the food
is there going to be an unintended
consequence of of this bill
thank you representative abramson for
the question my my understanding my
reading of the the language in the bill
would be that
if that product is arriving at the
supermarket in seabrook
pre-packaged
uh from say massachusetts and it has
pack you know polystyrene packaging
then
there would be nothing that the owner of
that store would have to or manager of
that store would have to do
they could sell that product as is
but if the you know
local farm was producing you know
sending apples
in a polystyrene tray from
i don't know kensington
um that would not be permitted that
farmer would be at a disadvantage in
terms of the types of materials that
they could use
versus the farmer uh apple farm in
amesbury mass
uh follow-up
well yeah just so you know you need to
look at the if you look at the bill uh
there is sections two and three to three
specifically says uh that you do not
need to repackage it if it came from out
of state right but so do you have a
further question or a different question
well my my question was about uh what
happens in places like starbucks
where they
to avoid the sales tax they have the
food prepared on another
uh
site so they then package
sandwiches and prepared foods and then
send it
to a starbucks store so they don't have
to pay the meals and rooms tax
uh data so we would have to pay rooms
and meals tax if it's rightfully
prepared off-site to avoid the tax but
then what happens if it comes in
polystyrene does this does the does the
store or restaurant have to dispose of
the food or they have to transfer to a
different type of container if the
contain if the food was pre-packaged and
assembled in massachusetts
um it could be massachusetts or new
hampshire once you have the food product
there and you notice that it's it's in
polystyrene do you then have to trace
back where the food came from and if it
came from a facility in new hampshire
you then have to transfer the food into
paper or
some other container the way i read this
bill in its language is that if it was
assembled and packaged and produced in
new hampshire
it would have to have
raw have to have something raw or
uncooked in there which i would think
eggs are uncooked so i'm not sure why we
if we really do need the egg exception
but
uh i certainly don't eat eggs raw except
you know
i guess elvis presley did but um this
but it if you have to read the
exemptions to to follow uh max but it
looks to me that uh it does appear that
if they if the prepackaged meal came
from massachusetts in that styrofoam
container they could leave it and sell
it in that but if it was uh made in new
hampshire with that pre that phone uh
that would be uh illegal under the
statute this bill
okay i'm just i am not a lawyer nor do i
pretend to be one
how you would take you know you have
something a polystyrene container in the
store
or restaurant how do you figure out
where that one specific item came from
if you're getting food from two
different facilities uh that is multiple
facilities so i guess you're questioning
the enforceability if you don't know
where you know who's going to enforce
this and based upon where it comes from
but
and to that point mr chairman if i may
in in comparing uh house bill 1564 to
this year's house bill 618
1564 last year had a fiscal note
relative to the bill it was
indeterminable based upon
the the
review by environmental services
but they clearly were talking about
enforcement issues
and the need for staff
and so i i'm not sure whether that would
apply to 618 i sense that it probably
would but i would uh leave that for the
uh committee's uh review it dodged the
fn didn't it
yeah
okay well thank you very much attorney
oh representative has a question yes
uh the question is for you mr chair do
we have someone from the grocer's
association um
on with us
uh we just gonna testify don't have
groceries but i do see henry veyu popped
up so we have
restaurants
but uh we do not have anybody from the
grocers or anyone from the health
department
and nobody from the health department
okay thank you
okay uh
the chair will now call on
uh yeah thank you
good morning thank you my name is
melissa gates and i'm the northeast
regional manager and a lobbyist for the
surfrider foundation and the ocean
speaking today
on behalf of our new hampshire chapter
in strong support of this bill and if
there's any doubt about the
recyclability of foam food wear i'd
direct your attentions to the lawsuit
that dart container corporation which is
the biggest phone footwear manufacturer
in the u.s has put considerable time and
funding into to try to prove their
argument that
expanded polystyrene foam food wear is
recyclable and the american chemistry
council actually spent over eight
hundred thousand dollars on this as well
in support of the new york city
restaurant action alliance
which rallied against new york city's
foam food ware ban and later filed a
lawsuit against new york city for that
foam food wear ban claiming that the
material shouldn't be banned because
it's recyclable however both of those
failed and new york city's department of
sanitation issued a determination on the
recyclability
that it is in fact not recyclable and
the court upheld this determination in
new york city won their lawsuit because
expanded polystyrene foam footwear is
not recyclable
the woods hole oceanographic institute
study referenced earlier actually
stipulates to hundreds of years for eps
to photodegrade as opposed to the
previously thought thousands of years
and of course the styrene that we're
referring to here is synthetically
derived from fossil fuels which is
distinct from naturally occurring
styrene
in this foam stuff i mean it is just
pervasive and it's consistently one of
the top 10 items we pull from new
hampshire's beaches during our monthly
cleanups
and scientists who study water quality
can stipulate that a randomly taken one
liter surface sample from anywhere in
the gulf of maine waters averages three
pieces of microplastics so we know that
plastic pollution is a problem
significant human health concerns from
the use of foam food wears are seated in
proven scientific foundations and are
cited in the written testimony i
submitted to this committee friday we
know that toxic components from foam
leach into food and drink and that heat
is a factor but it's not the only factor
alcohol and acidity also come into play
which means that when you drink coffee
or alcohol whether it's cold or hot or
you eat hot or greasy food out of a foam
container that you are in fact ingesting
toxins at a level that the world's
leading health experts tell us probably
causes cancer this alone really warrants
government intervention to protect human
health by passing laws to ban this toxic
food wear but then we can also add in
the pervasive environmental concerns
including that this bio accumulating
toxin entering our waterways through
intentional and non-intentional
littering leaching carcinogens into the
water being mistaken for food and
ingested by aquatic wildlife that some
humans then ingest
further adding in that foam is wreaking
havoc in our landfills and incinerators
where it ends up because foam food wears
cannot be recycled and add that this
material is so lightweight that it
easily crumbles and flies all over the
place with its non-biodegradable plastic
nuisance that will be with us for
hundreds and hundreds of years we can
see
very clearly why state after state is
passing regulation to ban this stuff
even during a global pandemic
multiple jurisdictions across the u.s
and the world are banning foam food wear
and allowing foam bands to come into
effect right in the middle of this
pandemic which indicates the severity of
the issue and some restaurants are
shifting away from single-use plastics
which is awesome and some consumers are
doing that as well but the rate of
voluntary compliance just isn't enough
and what's more we know that the
petrochemical plants that make foam are
disproportionately situated in
communities of color making black and
brown people who live near these plants
outside of new hampshire sick so that
new hampshire businesses can continue to
use foam food wares which are then
literally choking the life out of our
watershed while exposing us all the
cancer-causing toxins that many people
mistakingly assume are safe because
they're not banned by the state
government i hope you'll agree that it's
time to take action by favorably
advancing this bill just like the states
of vermont maine maryland new york new
jersey all counties of hawaii have done
to ban this stuff and all of our
adjacent states without current foam
bands including mass rhode island and
connecticut all have active legislation
advancing
many of which would have passed in the
last session but not for covid
and we also have multiple local laws
banning foam food ware products across
all those states that don't currently
have active state legislation or state
law rather banning the product
so i appreciate your time
and consideration of this bill and i
hope that you'll vote it favorably
forward
great thank you very much uh any
questions from the committee members no
i don't see any so thank you
and i'll now invite uh henry veyu who
did appear
yes
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee for the record
my name is henry value and i'm here on
behalf of the new hampshire
lodging and restaurant association um
and i just say that uh you know the
restaurant members aren't tone deaf
i think uh they know that uh
folks want uh restaurants to move on to
environmentally friendly
uh
products
and some restaurants have already made
that step
if you've been to a common man
restaurant
you know they already do the paper
straws they've gone
totally comprehensive
other restaurants aren't able to do all
that yet uh and some of it does come
down to cost uh
you look at the alternatives um
you know some can be
six cents uh
per unit uh difference in price um so it
does have a you know a cost impact
um
so i think the difference between the
proponents of this legislation in the
industry i think is
uh the pace
at which the change is going to happen
uh the proponents of this bill
have july 1 2022 as a drop dead date
everybody's gonna move over
um
which is ten months away uh and if you
think about restaurants right now and
some of them hanging on by their
fingertips
uh and take out being basically the
thing that's keeping them alive
uh
many of which never thought they'd be
doing this much take out prior to covet
so right now you know their whole cost
structure has just changed dramatically
uh with covid
uh and
so i think the timing of this right now
particularly saying 10 months from now
everybody's got to change over uh when
they're just trying to figure out how
they're going to get through
you know the rest of the spring uh
is summer going to be back to somewhat
normal you know with the new strains
coming on are we still going gonna have
the protocols in place are people still
are people gonna want to go to
restaurants
and so i think the
the timing of it right now just uh uh
you know is a challenge for a lot of
restaurants that have been thinking
about it but want to make sure there's
buy-in from their
patron community that it's going to cost
a little more i think people that go to
common man recognize okay we're making
you know investment in our environment
and they're happy uh you know to uh to
pay the extra cost um so
again we're not tone deaf i think it's
just the pace at which the change is
going to occur that's where the
difference allies and we would argue
that
this bill saying 10 months from now
everybody's going to switch over
when they're all just trying to
hang on by their fingernails makes it
difficult so with that i'm happy to
answer any questions okay thank you uh
we do have a couple of questions
representative bartlett
thanks very much mr chair
so um mr value then we can um we would
able to count on your support if we made
this july 1st of 2022
is that correct if you could retain the
bill
okay no that wasn't the question i asked
you
um
again i we don't know when you know
i'd love to know when business is gonna
be back to normal and that was one of
the things uh mike's always talking to
mike summers who's the president of the
association you know even when we come
out of this i think there's still going
to be some lag time uh when people are
going to be so used to taking out
uh
so
i i would prefer the committee retain
the bill
ask a follow-up further question may
inquire thank you mr chair
so if we retain the bill and we change
the date
to
july 1st of 2022
could we count on
the new hampshire restaurant and lodging
association to support this action
i think the association would prefer
that the members can do it at their pace
and again i think a lot of restaurants
have already
moved over uh to other alternatives
um
and um i think you know we'll get there
it's the hard fast date i think that
so that would be a no
that's i guess that's correct yeah okay
all right
the other questions from the committee
members
uh seeing them uh thank you very much
for your testimony
and
i see no hands up
you know i had more people who said they
wanted to speak but i guess no that's
not that bad
all right
it's 11 57 unbelievable okay
so we will close the public hearing on
house bill 618 and we had 113 people in
support
and 13 opposed with
nobody
being neutral
with that um we will adjourn
the committee until uh for lunch
and at 1 15. unless anybody has any
questions everybody else set the
committee
okay we'll see you
at 1 30 mr chairman 1 30. oh okay did i
do that what did i do that for
okay
well i guess i was i was worried about
these these those two three were gonna
run over and i
put a little buffer in there but okay 1
30. we'll see everybody at 1 30.
thank you pam for doing it
anytime
um pam can i just ask if you're going to
send a testifying list to us for this
afternoon
yes i am thank you i like to wait and to
give people the more than if i can yep
uh so gail i i promoted you but so you
can talk to me but uh we have it during
the hearing i'm sorry i didn't see your
hello yes hi
oh okay there
um i'm sorry i did send in um
a card i thought that said i wanted i i
had you on the list and i just didn't
see you and i guess i should have
let you know you need to raise your hand
for me to see you uh-huh okay
um did you have written testimony i do
it i i hope it uh i went it sent yeah i
would send i sent it to the commerce
good all right so we've all got will
yeah we got it thank you gail okay good
i apologize for not seeing you i'm
did you know or didn't tell you to raise
your hand and anything probably but i
just didn't tell you to raise your hand
so i apologize and i'm still learning
how to do this apology accepted it
so but
thank you thank you very much and we'll
we'll make sure everybody notes that you
were in support of the bill
okay
and i guess that's pretty much
everybody
okay
this
you
so
this
hey chris
did you go out did you just go out and
shovel
well i didn't exactly shovel but i snow
i used my snowblower
oh i don't even think the snowblower
would touch this stuff
well it's very heavy it's it it up here
we got about two inches except for it
blue and then there's like a foot and
then it rained and sleeted on top of
that freeze it's raised so it's like
cement it is it's tow cement i just did
about 45 minutes of it and i'm exhausted
yeah i i use my machines so
john john what's the snow like down your
way
we won't tell anybody it's just between
us what's that background yeah yeah i'm
always looking i'm always in concord
you could be in the virgin islands right
now
uh i could but i don't know if the zoom
works internationally
i noticed that there's some apps when i
was when i'm in the caribbean because i
go there every winter um that there are
times where there's some things i can't
run because they say they won't they
don't work internationally
so like pandora i can't get my pandora
music when i'm when i'm in the british
versions but
whether zoom works or not i don't know
but uh well certainly you've heard from
rindge and you must know that they've
gotten something i i i have to admit i
have not
because um this uh we had yesterday was
we had a renter
who's been coming for years and years
and years and years
and so they came in on monday and and
because
because uh they're they're
usual you know they've been there so
many times so i haven't heard anything
but the good news is that my uh employee
i insisted on him volunteering
to help out with the vaccines how about
the national guard and keene and he got
his vaccine yesterday so
so he's so happy i haven't heard from
today
no this is one of those no news is good
news
so so i went out to my chicken coop at
lunch time
oh
look at that that's a funny looking
chicken
it's a possum
oh wow oh my gosh it's a baby possum i
don't know how it got in there all the
won't it kill the chickens did you know
what
yeah
funny it's cats that aren't allowed so
you're you're okay and wheels
weasels will kill weasels will kill with
measles yeah you don't want to eat these
anymore no i've had a weasel and they
killed many many of my chickens one day
pardon me did you leave the possum in
there
uh no jack and i could pass them out
i squirted him that squirted him out
yeah we had the gloves and we had a net
and uh yeah it's gone and you weren't
short of any chickens how about eggs no
ah one egg had been eaten but
see some there are some people who do
some things that eat raw eggs
[Laughter]
i took my dog for a walk he went outside
roll lay down on his back and he refused
to move
yeah
mine wanted to stay out in a puddle
puddles yeah puppies puppies love metals
absolutely loves puddles loves snow up
to her ears she bounces around in it
it's a marvel yeah
well it is invigorating to go out with a
puppy for a walk it really is it's not
like me strolling the neighborhood it uh
keeps me alert well you know we're
having trouble getting ours to heal
she's she wants to want the alpha and
run forward run run ahead and
so so we're trying to train it to to
heal you know put we have a little leash
tight leash and keep saying he'll he'll
give her the treat when she does but
it's been been a challenge
you know john i'm working on something
like that with my pup and of course
she's little so she's not getting it but
what what i'm doing is i just put my
finger down at my side where i want her
to be and i walk like that
and if i speed up or slow down she does
the same thing
the only thing is distractibility so if
a squirrel goes by my finger is like
lost
but she does heal and i use the word
walk but if my finger's down and there's
no distraction she will walk so i'm
figuring it out
try pointing yeah yeah uh she sees it as
and i have to tell the first to look at
me so i hold the treat up here oh okay
yeah you
and then got the treat
treat in this hand and my finger down
and she's she's catching on that's good
or she's not catching on to anything
else but you know
pick your battles
that's a good one to start with
what kind of dog john
so we have a black lab
and we we have um we have another black
lab who's 14 years old
and so this is sort of minnie me
uh different different breeder and
everything but but uh she they look very
very similar and
very adorable
i love labs
and they are very faithful and honest
and they don't run away too much like my
beagles used to do i i used to have
beagles and
i had a beagle they're they're a
nightmare sometimes and they're very
cute and they're puppies but uh
but when you can hear one howling around
but
well that was not my best morning in
terms of moving things along other than
timing timing was good we could get
through there but timing was good but
you know and i looked out and i had the
red light was on it so i don't know how
i
but this is i'm out of some my summer
house so who knows
technology's
old and decrepit and who knows what it's
thinking
oh you know what that comment probably
went right over the head of new members
if your phone rang during committee
earring you had to put five dollars in
the coffee jar for coffee and chocolates
right i remember that well and the
commerce committee always had plenty of
money
[Laughter]
margie said the word blurb she had to
so blurb yeah because you're not
supposed to say players but there's no
way you know i've been doing it for 30
years there's no way i'll give up saying
blurbs
but you know what i mean you know right
majority report yeah what the heck is
that i don't know
i know what i've learned about
all right it's 1
and i see the sponsor is here so i'm
going to move him over
and
[Music]
hello
and
because i did see keith heath you're on
right
my clerk i am on i just have one thing
to interject if i if i could
one of the speakers from last session uh
called me during the break melissa gates
from uh
the surfers association
she said people had signed up and they
were expecting to be called to speak but
uh maybe you were relying on the hands
going up and they weren't able to put
hands up yeah so yeah no i got there was
one person at the end there that she
that wanted to uh um that i missed but i
apologize to her
but i i guess i didn't say ray's hands
or i guess i i
i guess i was so marveled by the fact
that we were right on time and no hands
were raised
i think it's just a learning curve for
the zoom thing
yeah for for people but for everybody i
got it yeah
emphasize the importance of raising
hands
okay representation you're on
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee
uh for the record i am representative
joshua keller from rockingham 33 which
includes the towns of brentwood
danville and fremont
and i am here today to introduce my bill
hp
uh
repealing the regulation of household
good carriers
um
that's specifically rsa 375 a and it is
essentially a requirement that movers
have a certificate of need
um
rsa
375 a regulates household mo goods
movers which offers operate only
interstate the interstate household good
movers are regulated by the federal
government
the reason i call this statute
certificate of need statute is um
is
the
which states that a proposed service
is required or
or will be required by the present or
future public convenience and necessary
necessity
otherwise such applications should be
denied
and so
there is a question uh
in my mind of why we are requiring them
to prove
that there is going to be a future
public convenience and necessity before
they're allowed to go into business also
um
in my research i found that there is
only about 34
companies
moving companies that fall into the
requirements of this chapter and both
maine and vermont do not regulate
household movers
and uh while the department of safety
said that they receive about one to two
complaints a year
most of which are resolved with just a
phone call um i was not able to find any
like rogue
movers
causing a problem in maine and vermont
via my internet searches to
see if that
that we are really stopping uh
problems by having this uh statute here
i think that it uh just
creates a barrier to entry for these
people having to prove that they um you
future public convenience and necessity
especially when they're competing with
national chains et cetera et cetera
so i just wanted to bring this to the
attention of the committee and i hope
that you would um
support the bill and i'm happy to answer
any questions
so why do you want to repeal it
because it's a certificate of need
that they have to prove that
i hate to say this but using that term
certificate of need for those of us in
the legislature a long time
has a huge implication certificate of
need is something we required of all
hospitals to prove right why they added
needed facilities so using that term is
a little stretch so
so you're you're simply saying it's this
statute's not needed is that the purpose
and you're saying well it's not really
needed it's not
yes thank you for the question i mean
yes i believe that it's not needed
because i don't
other states don't have it and they
don't have an issue with not having it
but also i think it's a barrier to entry
to require
the um people
seeking the certificate of need to prove
that
their business is required by present or
future public convenience and necessity
which is
listed in the statute otherwise their
application for the certificate would be
denied so that is my issue with this
statute
at its root yeah thank you
all right
representative van halton
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative yokola
i must admit i did some research on this
last night to not much avail and i'm
still not sure from your explanation
what the certificate of need is here
you're talking about movers mover
company moving companies
at present under this statute do they
have to prove that there is a need for
their service or maybe i should just rot
more broadly would you elaborate on what
you mean please okay thank you for the
question um i would point you to um the
last sentence of rsa
375 a
collabory
so that is what is guiding whether or
not
these certificates shall be
issued and in that requirement
um
as i've i've alluded to and and
reference a few times there is a
a requirement
that
the
there only be a certificate issued
when
the commissioner um
decides
or
concludes that the proposed service that
these people are trying to provide
is
or will be required
by the present or future public
convenience and necessity
otherwise the commissioner uh
follow up please okay for the question
we inquire um thank you
so
according to the statute as it exists
the statute that you want this section
repealed from
yes it's possible that there's no need
for movers
is that the intent of the step perhaps
i'm
so here's what i did i just
i just promoted up we do have someone
from the department of transportation
and i realized that there you have a
question and representative west have a
question but maybe we should hear from
him and have him explain to us
how they're treating that stat that
phrase that statute and whether they
really
are you guys okay with having having so
uh josh would you stick around in case
you know we might have some more
questions for you but but absolutely
i think what i'd like to do is bring up
eric marshall who can maybe um
explain to us uh is there is it really
true that you
we
that you could reject someone because he
couldn't really prove why
we needed this
mover uh hello my name is eric marshall
i'm from department of safety road toll
bureau uh yeah we can they have to go
through a hearing
okay uh really the hearings uh office
that decides whether they can be
rejected but
i can't recall everyone ever being
rejected in the 10 years that i've been
in this position so
um yes they can be rejected but have i
ever witnessed one no
so
i hope that answers your question
all right so so maybe that element of
the statue is is a little old and
archaic i guess
um but is it is there uh what is the
compelling safety issue for the state to
to regulate
these drivers
relate these uh regulate these moving
companies
um i would i can't i wouldn't be able to
answer that right now but i can get you
an answer to that uh
mostly uh through uh our troop g is the
one who does the enforcement on it and
i'd have to know if they've ever had any
safety issues so i could ask them
okay um
other than that i i don't recall
you know
hearing anything any safety issues we
regulate
uh
you know they have to submit tariffs and
their rates and stuff like that so
really that's what we monitor
um so as far as safety is concerned with
their vehicles and
and uh things like that we we don't do
that in our in our section troop g does
that so but the safety would be they
would they're just like any truck that's
running around in new hampshire you know
exactly yes you don't treat them
differently okay
all right so connie uh representative
van halen do you want to pursue your
question no no i i think it's been
clarified i'm just um stunned that this
type of thing exists
for movers and apparently not for a
great deal of other other people so uh
no thank you and thank you john for
helping to clarify as well as a
representative
my assumption is that when you have
federal regulating for for
um interstate commerce that somebody
thought somewhere along the line thought
it was probably appropriate to make sure
that in-state
was it was had a parallel law you know
much much like the same thing we had
with uh
with food safety uh representative
bartlett
you there you got it
oh you just there you go there sorry
um phone range just as you're calling me
um
i'm
confused i guess
um
so there's no one from the state that
tells us why we have to have this other
states don't have it are we the
representative we the only state that
thank you for the question um actually
no we
so there are
um 46
states
or 40 40
42 44 states so there are six states
that do not have it um of those states
we are boarded by two of them um also
alaska delaware utah and wisconsin don't
have the these um types of regulations
they don't regulate them at a um at all
but um
there
some of them do have the re the um
the
uh certificate of need type of language
in there um
in other states like massachusetts has a
certificate of need type of language in
their statute
um but i wasn't i didn't verify that all
of that all of the
44 other states had their certificate of
need type of language in their statutes
but this is a 30 year old statute so
it's may ask you just about the little
question for the question being inquired
thanks pretty much um i'm sorry to
belabor this
so if 44 states have this requirement
and new hampshire is presumably one of
the 44
um
six states decided to get rid of it was
do you know whether it was
recent that they got rid of this
requirement i i am concerned that
there's no one from
the state that can answer why this is in
place i guess
yeah because
christie the state whenever we ask any
whether it's our insurance department
so so they can tell us what's the
compelling reason to keep it
maybe
i mean well we have a complaint once a
year but you know they it's it's hard to
get them to defend the statue they're
there that that we
that we passed
i mean that response certainly that's my
concern is that that i understand they
won't take a position i'm just
concerned that we're one of
what most of the states have but there's
okay would you believe yeah thank you
thank you
sorry thank you for the thank you for
the court uh question and i did want to
um clarify my last statement that it
hasn't been this statute hasn't been
amended in the last 30 years
um but i did ask um i did try and get um
information i did ask ols whether or not
these um
six states that
that don't have the regulation if they
repealed it and when
and the
the ols
looked back as far as they could um and
they didn't see that there was a repeal
and so it's possible
that they just never had uh any
requirement
and so
uh
and obviously not all the all the
statutes would be the same so some
states may regulate more or less
um than our state but those six states
they did not find any statute ever
existing for regulation of those uh
household good movers so
i hope that was requested
thank you
uh thank you thank you for taking my
question
i actually was rather surprised to hear
that there are several complaints every
year considering that there are only 34
companies doing this
and i'm wondering if you have a sense of
what those complaints are and whether
it's one particular company that's uh
involved with the complaints and whether
this repealing this would make that
okay that i guess that's for you josh
but um it is for josh yes thank you
thank you uh
for the question i
would have to direct you to the
department and because i only asked how
often they are coming up with issues i
did not ask which specific companies and
and get into the nitty-gritty detail of
what each complaint was about they they
just said that most of the the um the
complaints were solved with just calling
the company um they they didn't they
didn't say that very often that they
even needed to contact
um
the troop to investigate more more fully
than just a phone call but they would be
better to answer that question i believe
yeah so eric can you help us out with
that one that question yes i can um
the complaints that we get are mostly uh
uh
also good carriers that are
certified with us uh
basically complaining about other
household good carriers out there that
are not
certified
that they donate
basically their competition
is uh they realize that they're not
certified they call us
we follow up
um and uh
we also and then we also forward it over
to uh troop g and uh normally that leads
to that company um becoming certified
with us you know through the hearing
process and everything so
so you're all set okay that's the next
and joyce and connor you guys are done
you want to put your hands down
are you oh you do have a question okay
yeah my question is well first my
observation is maybe there aren't that
many complaints because there is a
certification process you have to go
through in order to get
able to do that business
so i'm i'm what i'm getting at is if if
you have a truck and a couple guys that
are brawny
and you slap a banner on and said moves
are us
uh you're good to go
but uh i don't think that's
i don't think that's the kind of
criteria
i think you have to have to be some
principles and criteria to get into a
business
and that i think is what a certification
process
is
and um
so my question is i'm not quite sure
exactly what benefit
is going to come to the puppy public at
large
because anybody who wants to doesn't
need to get a certification in order to
do a business
and and that's the uh that's the issue i
i
i that worries me
and it may not sound
you know my question is would you
believe i think that
in most professional
endeavors
there are certification processes that
are required
and it doesn't surprise me
uh that uh
there is such a thing here when it comes
to moving people's personal belongings
especially if you go across interstate
lines
so i i don't know what you i don't know
what you hope to accomplish here
representative hunt you're muted
[Music]
robert i have a new person here bill
burke
it says new hampshire sp says is that
uh can you hear me sir yes we can yes i
am with new hampshire state police troop
gene okay
right oh you are troop j then okay so
yes sir all right so uh we're gonna
continue to questions but i'm i want you
this is this is a oddball hearing i
never had a hearing like this before but
it's sort of almost a subcommittee but
uh because we're all just trying to get
our arms around this issue so uh connie
do you want to go uh representative van
houden you want to go ahead with your
question yes thank you and and thank you
representative for again indulging me
i'm just curious as to how this issue
came to your attention what brought your
eye to this it's not something that the
average person would know about was
there an issue or concern that brought
thank you for the question um so there
is some agencies out there that look and
rank state by state bar for how
hard it is to get into certain types of
fields and stuff and the barriers that
that are there
and so it was brought to my attention
through those types of um organizations
that said okay there's um
essentially a certificate of need type
of thing here and so
um that creates a barrier to entry where
they have to prove themselves and so
that's an unusual hurdle that they
classified as you know pretty bad so i i
wanted to bring it to the attention of
of uh the committee and the literature
as well but instead of instead of just
getting rid of that clause you decide to
just get rid of the whole regulation
because
right
yes so thank you for the thank you for
the question um yes i i looked um
at the statute and i didn't see any
anything that that uh
really
brought the safety
to new hampshire and so and since
there's other states that don't have it
i really um didn't think that it was
entirely necessary and since as the um
the
department has has just testified
that uh the complaints really are just
from other people not being licensed not
from
nefarious actors uh who could see me so
yeah so what are we asking uh so um mr
burke um i i don't know what your title
is so
what's your um could you could you help
us out a little bit about the complaints
and how many complaints and was there
any is there any consistent one being
complained or is it really just
people complaining that other unlicensed
uh moving companies are out there
well usually the complaint will come
into um
rotol
because that's
they they regulate that
i i can tell you on the federal motor
carrier side because we enforce the
federal motor carrier rules and
regulations
we we do all the truck enforcement we're
the truck guys out there right you're
the trucker yes household goods people
are extremely regulated through federal
motor carrier
because of things that have happened in
the past things like hostage freight
happens where you pay a mover
say he gives you a quote of you know two
thousand dollars to move your goods from
point a to point b
if you cross state lines you fall under
federal motor carriers regulations and
federal motor carrier would deal with
that issue but if you move safe from
nashua to guilford
well that's interest state federal motor
carrier is not going to get involved in
that
so
i believe and i can't say it for sure i
just got notified about this today
um
this was all brought up in the 80s when
this was kind of the hotbed thing they
would say okay we're gonna charge you
two thousand dollars to move your goods
from point a to point b
so once they pick up your goods they say
well it took a little bit more than we
had to do so it's now four thousand
dollars and you're not getting your
stuff back until we get paid
so
the regulations came about due to things
like that
and there's other things that i look at
when i've looked at the statute today
like it mandates they have to have
insurance so if the truck catches fire
with all your household goods inside of
it and this guy has no insurance
what's going to happen to all your stuff
who's going to pay for all that
doesn't your homeowners cover that
i don't know if your homeowners does or
not but i would want that carrier to be
insured for all my stuff if the truck
caught fire or got an accident or
something i would uh not that i'm an
expert on this subject
but i did have a camera stolen out of a
car and
they told me i get that covered under my
home owners oh okay so awesome leave
your home owners use it so but it is
true if you're moving your whole house
from one house to another you might not
have you might be in between homeowners
right you might have canceled your old
home and haven't set up your new home
um so there's there's a lot of things
that that come about through this
usually if we get a complaint it's
usually through federal motor carrier
because
new hampshire did it smart in my opinion
way way back in the 80s we adopted under
266 72a we adopted all the federal not
all but most of the federal motor
carrier rules and regulations
from cdl licensing to how trucks operate
to
um you know how they have to perform
mechanically on the side of the road
some states have
to do
the federal rules and then they have
their own state rules
so you could be legal
in the state but violating federal rules
and vice versa and that gets very
confusing for trucking companies
so new hampshire just said these rules
are ours
but when you look at the statute one
statute they did not put in there for
federal mortar carrier was 375.
so i believe that's why the state went
and made their own rules
their own regulation
under our own 375
to
okay so representative bartlett you're
still top of the list for questions here
you thanks very much um
uh representative ukela
you said that there were agencies that
identify um
complaints like this i would like to
know what agency identified you
notified you or you notified them that
thank you for the thank you for the
question um so
i
i looked up on the on a website called
um freedom in the 50states.org
that's what had
um
that was actually one of the states that
i looked at to
decide that i was going to move to new
hampshire when i decided to move to new
hampshire so um i'm very familiar with
that
they rank the different states on
different uh
different um regulations
all different types of things so
that that was the
so this site
so this agency
you so you use this as your
go-to place to figure out if
there's too many regulations
no no so i was just reading
so when i when i
was deciding on where i wanted to live
in this country i i read a bunch of
different um
states kind of like summaries
and um one of the things listed
was that we regulate household goods
carriers
as as one of the things that they
brought up and so
when i was
researching that regulation that's when
i found
that we have this um
issuance requirement and so i thought
that that was
i i think that when we got rid of it for
um i thought it was unusual that we
would have this requirement when we got
rid of it for
um
hospitals so
for that reason i thought what this is i
think something that that
fell through the cracks kind of a thing
totally different animals yeah i was
just going to say i'm not sure
however don't be a gracious once someone
gave me a board game called silly laws
and i said well i can win this game i'll
i know it so it wasn't
the silly law for new hampshire i did
not know this one and it was you can't
uh they at a pawn broker you can't take
your jacket off and try to pawn your
jacket
believe it or not that's still in the
statute and no i never went and tried it
well we'll be looking for that one for
representative
yeah thank you for my question and thank
you for your testimony um representative
this might be a question for the
agencies
yeah in the statute um i'm just pulling
it up here so i can read it
section 375 a colon three
it's just kind of odd that there's a
there's a determining determination
about what is
present what is required by the present
or future
public convenience and necessity
how would
no offense but how would a government
bureaucrat
know what the future
necessity is
or the future public convenience how
would you possibly make that
determination
did one of you want to dare to take that
question
eric or bill
um the only thing i would have to could
say i can't answer that because these
these go before hearings and they're the
ones that would that our hearings bureau
and they're the ones that decides on
that i mean i could
i can't even begin to
try to answer that i have no idea sorry
to say but i can find out if they have
an opinion on it
i mean it would have to be based on some
kind of data right and how do you
predict what a future market is going to
look like that just seems
impossible
yeah and that's i mean i don't go
through the hearings process we just set
up the hearings and and off they go over
it over to them so
um
i could try to find out if there's a
history there
what do you think what do you think
officer burt
uh well i'm not quite sure i kind of
looked at that as like maybe if they
were to it looks like you at one point
you can sell your your uh
your license to say to someone else if
you were to sell the business and maybe
that's for the future
person that may buy it like they would
have to like
selling a taxi medallion yeah i don't i
don't see excuse me for jumping in i
don't see anything about selling your
stuff this looks like when it's issued
or denied so i'm looking at 375-a
colon three
yeah i
like eric i'm not familiar with it this
probably dates back it goes back to when
there was railroads and
and whether you really want to move or
move things by truck versus really i
mean i i would have to say this was that
this did start in the public utilities
commission and came over to us so
and it's been around a long time
okay uh
representative weston
yes thank you uh thank you for taking my
question this may actually be for the
state people i'm wondering if there's a
fee involved with getting this
certificate
there's a
50 fee
they pay
for they pay that to us before the
hearing then after the hearing when it's
approved it's a ten dollar
uh
renewal fee every year
a follow-up for the question may inquire
um
i
would have to get back to you on that
the 50 fee i basically it's a it's a
it's a
application fee as far as i know
so
is this a self-funded group uh this
department are you depre is your
oh what safety
oh i know
okay i'm a little confused with who's
with what department here okay yeah
they're both department of safety
but the one is troop g so he's a state
trooper and the other one is from there
was one point in time
the highway the highway group was not
part of the state troop they were
actually a separate entity so erica's
was is from is uh as they called tolls
and it was a different division that got
merged in the department of safety
okay thank you if i had that correct
oh i was just gonna
comment or maybe do it would you believe
that
we still have the new hampshire's
dumbest law contest going every year and
i and this kind of came to mind as soon
as uh
the sponsor brought this up
this is a good one okay this might be an
act this might be an opportunity for
that
okay there's any other uh
questions for these gentlemen
thank you both i appreciate you both
standing in and helping us out here with
us all right so
i have no one else who uh who's signed
up to speak so i'm going to make sure
anybody in the attendees if you would
like to speak would you please raise
your
hand and um
let's see we have some liquor people
um
i don't see anybody and i should joyce
your hand system because it's still up
all right so if i have no more other
questions about this bill again i want
to thank you guys for coming in and
helping us out we appreciate it
and i will close the public hearing
and i have uh seven people in support uh
one neutral which is of the department
and one opposed so there was somebody
who was opposed
the yetin flammer
who is a member of the public
and with that um i will close the public
hearing on
house bill 207
and we're right on time okay so the next
one
all right so this is another another
awkward
bill okay um open up the public hearing
on house bill 333
and
i
see
[Music]
uh representative nuns
were you there yeah there you are okay
you don't have to raise your hand i'll
i'll just move you over right now i got
you
okay
the regulation is
the preparation distribution sale of
creighton
products good afternoon mr chairman
and members of the committee thank you
so much for hearing me today for
for the record my name is herschel nunez
and i am a state representative in
hillsborough district 37 towns of hudson
and pelham i live in pelham
um i am here today to introduce hb 333
relative to the sale and distribution of
kratom products
otherwise known as the kratom consumer
protection act
uh now i'm going to disclose to you guys
that i am not an expert in kratom but i
do did do some research and i do have
friends that use the product so uh when
i was uh asked to sponsor a bill i was i
was good with it so let me tell you i
did a little bit of research i found out
a few things about about kratom
it's been around since the late 1800s uh
from when it's been recorded in history
however it began being more widely used
in the united states around uh in the
1980s late 1980s
uh the the the real name mitro gina
speciosa
i guess that would be the scientific
name for kratom
it's an all-natural supplement that's
native to southeast asia
thailand malaysia and indonesia are a
few of the countries that where it grows
because it needs the right type of
alkaline soil and humidity to grow
now kratom uh is a product that is used
uh
as both a stimulant and as a sedative it
has compounds for both uh there are
different strains and the most popular
way of using the product is by making a
tea from it or adding it to another
beverage like orange juice one of my
friends does that he puts a scoop in his
orange juice in the morning
in small doses it acts as a stimulant
and in larger doses it acts as a
sedative
its effects have been known to increase
a person's productivity it has mood
enhancing capabilities
anti-anxiety properties
it can be a natural antidepressant and
among many of the consumers who
currently use the product they are
having fewer
negative effects than they would if they
the effects of kratom can be felt uh
within five to ten minutes after
ingesting it and uh
it will stay in the person's system from
two to five days and depending on how
much the person use it could it could be
longer than five days
uh i believe if i'm right it's the
cousin of a coffee bean plant
when you order it or you purchase it
you'll receive it in a leaf form or
in the research i did find out that it
can be toxic if in high doses
if it's taken improperly
there could be a small addictive piece
to it if it's taken improperly
and for all of these reasons above are
the reasons why we're bringing hb 333 to
you today
now i was approached by a constituent
who's going to be speaking behind me
today mr seamus casey
uh who has done a lot of work in this
state
and he is probably the biggest advocate
of kratom also behind me is uh matt
hatto from the american kratom
association
they did not have to work hard to
persuade me to bring this bill forward
in my personal history i've never
purchased this product or used this
product but i do know many who have and
in each and every case they've told me
that it truly helps them
one of my friends is a veteran he
suffers from ptsd
and he takes kratom every morning this
is the guy with the orange juice
he takes kratom every morning and he
said that if it wasn't for this product
that he just didn't know how he would be
able to operate
a few others i know tell me that it can
help them focus and be alert
and that they're just much more
productive
now i'm not normally one to bring a bill
forward that creates regulation or grows
the size of government but
i also feel that there should have
probably been a financial note that was
added to this bill but it didn't come
out of ols that way
but as you'll hear from those behind me
the experts in the industry and others
who are going to testify
many of them are asking for the
regulation from both the industry and
the consumers
um
the product is currently legal
and they just want to make sure that the
product can only be sold unadulterated
in its true form
and within the bill there are there are
provisions of how it needs to be sold
they do not want it tainted with other
products and i i would agree with
anybody on any type of
product or compound that you're using
like other substances can make it act
differently and definitely not
substances that are listed in the
controlled substance act we wouldn't
want any of that and you need to be 18
years old to purchase it
there are violations that are built into
bill concerning the sale of the product
but it is considered as a food product
or a dietary supplement
now again i'm not the expert but i do
feel that we have an obligation to
listen to our consumers and industries
especially when they together are
requesting our help
and um
we'd like to try to get ahead of any
scheduling it is it is not illegal now
and there have been some wins in this
area and the people behind me are going
to talk to you about that
i would like for them to talk more of
that we've had some wins in states and
wins federally about this product
we we just want to make sure that
something gets created in new hampshire
to protect our consumers
now a kratom bill was brought before the
senate last term sb 758
and while it was delivered as a bill to
ban the product the senate chose to
amend it and turn it into a bill to
regulate the product
uh now this was passed in that body as
an ought to pass with amendment but it
died on the table last june as did many
other bills that we know of
in my submitted written testimony i
provided some links to the source
information to the introduction of this
bill
and i will give you a couple of facts
before i start closing out here
for time's sake
in a cnn health article dated april 2019
u.s food and drug administration stated
that 44 deaths have been associated with
kratom
but in almost all of these cases there
were other substances in their body at
the time at the time of death now this
is less than a percent
uh of all the over over overdose deaths
and when i went out to try to find
something else that may have been
similar in that type of reporting
it was
sort of equivalent to numbers of those
who may have overdosed by aspirin
so
with that i'm going to try to answer any
questions you have but i truly feel i
should defer most of the questions to
those testifying behind me as they'll be
able to answer them more effectively but
i in closing i do feel that listening to
our constituents and the industries
especially when they agree
is a good way for us to find a path to
provide predict protections and consumer
needs
and with that i'll say thank you for
hearing my testimony and i'll take any
questions that you have and i hope i can
answer them
good uh first up is representative abel
uh thank you uh
representative uh nunes uh for your
testimony um i'm a little confused about
what this bill is trying to achieve
we have a substance
that is
not regulated not prohibited
already available to the consumer
and i don't
maybe you can tell me a little bit more
about why we need to
uh
pass a law that would regulate whether
other substances are combined in this it
it just doesn't make sense to me at this
point thank you
thank you representative abel for the
question and let me see if i can answer
this for you the correct way um we're
asking for a regulation to be put in on
the bill for a couple of reasons we want
to make sure that number one it's only
sold to those that are 18 years of age
or older
second thing is is that it needs to be
in an unadulterated form
um kratom can be
sold and mixed with other items and if
it's not labeled properly
you don't you don't know what's in there
we want the labeling to happen we want
we want for
the the consumers that choose to buy the
product to know that they're getting an
unadulterated product
and we also want them to be of legal age
okay
uh next up is representative emerson
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative nunez for taking my
question um on the question of labeling
obviously kratom does have some side
effects although i guess they're fairly
rare on the question of labeling is your
um
preference to handle it
uh or intent to handle it through
statute or uh just stick with the common
law
uh duty to notify the consumer
thank you representative abramson for
the question i would think that we would
probably build in a methodology to this
of what needs to happen through the
regulation um i'm going to defer part of
this question over to
those who are speaking behind me that
have more uh experience in the industry
but but i do think that again we're
talking about having labels that uh that
prove that it's unadulterated uh because
uh it does have effects if something
else is mixed in with the product
all right thank you very much thank you
okay uh
representative burrows
yes thank you for taking my question um
my question is i'm actually wondering
why we aren't
discussing banning this product given
that the fda
has not approved it
they state it's been linked to
hallucinate hallucinations seizures and
liver damage they said there's no
scientific evidence to support the uses
including withdrawal from heroin
morphine and other opioids and they warn
people from using it so why why why
aren't we why are we talking about
regulating it why aren't we talking
about banning it
thank you representative burroughs for
that question now i believe that we're
going to have some testimony coming in
behind me that's going to answer this
question for you
i do know that federally it's been
chosen just recently
to be able to stay on the market
and there were a couple of wins in a few
other states recently that uh that are
putting this type of regulation in on
top of it
uh there are many products that are out
there
that can do exactly what you just said
and
there are many products that are out
there that are dietary supplements which
is what we consider this to be a dietary
supplement uh something that can help
you i look at it personally and those
behind me may not agree with me but
personally i look at it like uh valeria
or
or a st john's wort or ginkgo biloba
but
the effects may be greater depending on
the dosage if you follow the
instructions and you and you consume the
product correctly the effect should be
as stated and that's why we're looking
for the regulation it is legal across
all 50 of the united states right now
follow up please
further question me inquire
do you do you believe or have you seen
evidence that there are some dietary
supplements that are actually unsafe and
dangerous
representative burroughs thank you for
the question
i'm not going to call this product
unsafe and dangerous
and that's how i'm going to answer your
question all right thank you
perfect
okay representative van halton
thank you and thank you representative
for your insights i have a couple of
questions um
one is that you just stated that it's
legal across all 50 states is it truly
legal is it by law legal or are we just
saying that it's not illegal
thank you representative van halen for
the question um
what i'm going to say is that uh is that
there have
there were some decisions
by the federal government just recently
that we're going to talk about in just a
few minutes but those who are testifying
behind me
and they're going to be telling you
about what happened with those
regulations
at one point i know that
the federal government
thought about putting it on a schedule
but they've since changed their mind
and uh
having said that that would that to me
thank you um and just another follow-up
which is related in your testimony and i
quote you said it is considered a food
product or a dietary supplement
which is it and who's made that
designation
um as i thank you representative for the
question as i stated earlier
i took this information from the kratom
society.com in an article dated
november of uh 2020
where they stated that it is a food
supplement
okay what's that
um all right thank you very much for
your testimony and um before i uh um
we speak you'll hear from um mr casey mr
howard i am uh to have colleen smith who
is from the department of uh health and
human services who is in opposition to
this bill
thank you chairman hunt and members of
the committee for the record my name is
colleen smith and i'm the administrator
of the food protection section within
the department of health and human
services
services is opposed to hb 333 as it is
currently written due to a direct
conflict with the department's food
safety regulations and technical
difficulties related to the
administration
of of the proposed requirements
the inclusion of kratom and the
definition of a food poses a regulatory
challenge for new hampshire the new
hampshire food safety rules adopt the
2017 u.s food and drug administration
food code the fda food code states that
food must be obtained from sources that
comply with federal state and local laws
and must not contain any prohibited
ingredients or additives there are no
fda approved uses for kratom
fda has issued warnings regarding the
serious risks associated with the use of
kratom fda is concerned that kratom
which affects the same opiate brain
receptors as morphine appears to have
properties that expose users to the risk
of addiction abuse and dependence
there are no fda approved uses for
kratom and the agency has reserved
received concerning reports about the
safety of its use
the department is also aware of reports
to the northern new england poison
center regarding earth adverse health
effects after exposure to kratom
according to data provided to the
to provided to us from the poison center
there were 94 reports of adverse health
effects from exposure to kratom from
2012 to 2019
whereby the food protection section's
mission is to ensure the safety and
security of the new hampshire food
supply including a substance and the
definition of food that has not been
demonstrated to be safe is in direct
conflict with our mission
while the bill
has criteria for
kratom to be sold there is not um
mentioned in the bill who
which agency would be responsible for
enforcing these requirements nor does it
provide a structure for the agency to
provide
to regulate kratom effectively
it does not provide standards to or
testing requirements to ensure consumer
product safety and it doesn't preclude
appropriation to support additional
staff and resources necessary
thank you for allowing me to present the
information and i'd be happy to take any
questions
okay
any questions from
okay uh
representative
uh yes thank you uh chairman uh where
where is this actually sold is it sold
at like health food stores uh
uh i don't know where you might be able
to get cbd or
i i've never heard of it
um
i am not aware of the full scope of
where this product is sold but i do know
antidotally i believe it would be
okay thank you
and representative abramson
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question you
mentioned kratom as
you know as something the food and drug
administration regulates both food and
drugs but they regulate them very
differently
what would be the problem with viewing
this as just a food product since people
are you know similar to coffee if uh
people are taking this as tea most of
the people who emailed us
over the years have said that they just
take this as a tea
sometimes for calming or for for or for
getting off of uh opioids or for getting
off of heroin or some other uh
drug problem but what would be the what
would be the problem with the state of
new hampshire viewing this as just an
herbal product that people can take as a
tea
so we do rely on
the
the federal
studies that approve this as a food
additive and currently for kratom there
is nothing
out there that proves its safety for
okay
hi
sorry about that
i forgot i had my screen
so
my notes here um
thanks for taking my question
um what states have passed a bill
i'm afraid i can't answer your question
some other people will listen to that
question for us
she's in opposition to the bill but we
do have supporters of the bill so i'm
sure they'll be able to answer that for
you
thank you and thank you for taking my
question you've done a really good job
of clarifying the the idea that this is
actually a food
it's also been noted to be a dietary
supplement what is your take on labeling
this as a dietary supplement
so
our section does not regulate
dietary supplements those are regulated
by the fda and
currently fda does not recommend this as
a dietary dietary supplement supplement
what's up
okay well great thank you very much mrs
um so i'm going to call on uh see mrs
casey now since he's from new hampshire
mac we'll get you next but uh
well thank you mr chairman can you hear
me yes we can
great thank you so thank you and thank
you members of committee for uh giving
me the opportunity to speak in support
of house bill 333
for the record my name is seamus casey
and i live in barrington new hampshire
unlike many of the speakers likely lined
up today i'm not here to speak from my
personal perspective about kratom
as i am not a consumer of it
i first learned about it from a personal
account of a friend she had been in an
awful car accident and was prescribed
some some form of opiate pain reliever
by her doctor
the side effects of this prescription
were debilitating greatly reducing her
quality of life fortunately for her her
doctor had another suggestion that she
looked into kratom for the pain relief
she did and because of this her quality
of life is restored
and as with her sharing her personal
story that put kratom on my radar like
many of you i had not heard of it prior
to that
some of you might know me as the
developer of a legislative tracking
system here in new hampshire it was
through that and due to my friend having
mentioned kratom that i have found
myself as an advocate for it here in new
hampshire
and now over the past five years i have
led the effort to block multiple
attempted bans so this is to address a
question earlier about
why aren't we talking about it we have
and a number of times and i'll give a
quick summary of that here
uh the first was in january
of 2016.
senate bill 540 sponsored by then
senator fuller clark was introduced as
prohibiting the possession use or sale
of kratom
five years ago to this very day the
senate health and human services
committee held a hearing for the bill we
had about 40 people show up in support
for the hearing where then chairman
sanborn very graciously made the time
for all to speak during the hearing he
expressed concerns that the bill would
quote trample civil liberties
the committee unanimously recommended
the bill be amended replacing it with
language that would simply require one
to be 18 or older whereas current there
is no statute or requirement of that in
the state now
the amendment was adopted and passed on
a voice vote the house criminal justice
and public safety committee soon
thereafter also recommended passage but
then a house floor motion to table it
was adopted the bill then died on the
table
in late 2016 i saw an lsr for 2017 lsr
number 78 titled prohibiting the sale or
use of kratom filed by rep massimilia
i reached out to her explaining the
recent history with senate bill 540 and
asked that she considered withdrawing
the lsr and she did
a year ago last week then senator feltes
introduced senate bill 758 titled
relative to bannon kratom
on march 3rd the senate health and human
services committee held a hearing for
the bill to his credit senator feltes
responded to pressure from crowd of
consumers and showed up at the hearing
with an amendment in hand that amendment
was an earlier version of the bill we
have before us today the crime consumer
protection act
i was in contact with some of the senate
health and human services committee
members and also with the governor's
office about taking this very action so
it was quite relieving to see the
sponsor come around to the to the idea
as well
i mentioned the governor as he and i
have had a conversation about the crowd
and consumer protection act back in
september of 2019
he was impressed with the list of of
other gov
of other governors who have signed into
law which at the time included the
states of utah georgia arizona and
nevada
per our conversation he seemed very
receptive to the idea
but back to seven uh sent to me senate
bill 758
the hhs committee unanimously
recommended the amendment to replace the
bill with the credit consumer protection
act the amendment was adopted and passed
on a voice vote but then covet happened
the bill was stalled until the senate
had to send it to the house the house
was forced to table it along with a
group of other bills due to there being
no means to hold public hearings these
bills all of course died on the table
this year rather than react defensively
to try to stop additional attempts at
banning it i wanted to start off by
preemptively introducing the crowd and
consumer protection act and i thank my
good friend representative nunes for
agreeing to sponsor it
the crime consumer protection act seeks
to proactively address concerns that
prompted the past attempts at banning it
while ensuring the the continued safe
availability of kratom for adults
uh mr chairman if i may ask i would
request that mack i'll follow up because
he is the best suited to speak on the
details of the kind of consumer tax of
the kcpa and the rationale of why the
states need to take action to protect
consumers where the fda has failed and
neglected their duty to do so
so thank you very much members of
committee and i will answer any
questions
okay
any questions from committee
see none okay mr adam you're you're up
chairman members of the committee thank
you so much for this opportunity uh to
speak about this important legislation
while i do not hail from new hampshire
my wife and i raised six children and
tried to instill in them the values of
independence and self-reliance and i
think that you would be proud to have
them as citizens of your great state
because at least five of them have
followed that advice for the most part
we have one you may want to accept may
not want to accept
but this is a great uh occasion for us
at the american kratom association i
serve as the senior fellow in public
policy and i've testified at more than
well dozens of hearings across the
country and states and i have heard
similar kinds of questions that have
been raised and in fact have heard some
of the comments that miss smith uh
reflected and and we are glad to work
with her and her department to resolve
some of those issues but if i could
reference first the written testimony
and i hope each of you will look at that
but perhaps i could but most efficiently
spend our time talking about some of the
issues that have been raised in the
question period obviously with the thing
we're trying to accomplish with the
kratom consumer protection act is to
provide protections for consumers from
unscrupulous vendors in the united
states who will adulterate the product
in order to get it to do something it
does not do kratom does not have a
reinforcing high that would drive people
to an addiction or to continue to
purchase their product and so some of
these vendors will add things like
heroin fentanyl and morphine in order to
induce that to increase their sales it
is done widely in the united states we
have found in the four states that have
enacted the kratom consumer protection
act a substantial reduction in the
number of those adulterated products
available on the store shelves for
consumers because these unscrupulous
vendors do not want to run afoul of the
laws in those states and we think it
affords a significant level protection
for consumers we think the age limit is
important as well uh we think that any
decision about this kind of product
and like tobacco or alcohol or or coffee
even probably i'd be done with the
advice and consent of parents
you should know that the the taste of
kratom is foul
children wouldn't be drawn to it unless
it has these adulterants in it uh
typically it doesn't give you the
reinforcing high as i mentioned it also
does it doesn't do something that's very
important and that is it does not impact
your your respiratory system as
traditional uh therapies and opioids do
with respect to the how kratom is
properly designated under the federal
food drug and cosmetic act the
classification of freight kratom as a
food is done
under that law and it is very specific
and is why the aka characterizes
it in that way the other thing that the
fdnc act does it requires that a
manufacturer of any product has to look
at the intended use of how it's marketed
and there is where the fda has in fact
legitimately raised questions about some
creative manufacturers who violate that
law and we fully support them from being
restricted from making any kind of
structure function claims as a dietary
supplement if it hasn't gone through the
new dietary ingredient notification
process or if they want to make
therapeutic claims to go through the new
drug application process but kratom
itself is a food it is not a food
additive it is a food itself under the
definition of characterization under the
food and drug act federally
the fda has
as they did back in the early 90s and
some of you may remember this
they went after vitamins and dietary
supplements at that time with the very
same characterizations and attacks on
those products at the time with the
claims that they were killing people
that there were an elevated number of
reports being made about adverse events
and that they were dangerous products
and should be uh banned and all should
be forced to go through the new drug
application process
in 1994 the congress contended with this
issue it is the first time in the
history of the switchboard at the
capitol that the capital was shut down
this was before emails
people called and they literally shut
down the switchboard objecting to the
fda's overreach of regulatory authority
restricting their freedoms and the the
ability to make informed decisions about
the products that they make today more
than 80 percent of the american
population uses dietary supplements and
vitamins in order to maintain their
health and well-being but those very
same attacks that they used against
vitamins and dietary supplements were
interdicted by the congress where they
passed the dietary supplement health and
education act congress the congress
restricted the fda's authority even
though they made the same claims then
against those products as they do today
against kratom the fda is alone in
washington dc in their attacks on kratom
they initiated this action largely based
on some deaths that were reported in
2009 where nine people died in the
12-month period allegedly from a kratom
product a powder crate and product sold
on the internet that got the attention
of every public health official in the
world and appropriately so but what the
fda failed to tell people after they
imposed an import alert and starting
filling the pipeline of information that
led to some states to be duped into
banning kratom
was that the kratom was dangerous it was
killing people they didn't tell that
there was a scientific paper
peer-reviewed and published that looked
at all nine of those deaths and every
one was the result of an adulterant
called odes methyl tramadol which is the
powerful uh chemical that's used in the
production of the opioid tranvidol the
same dose of which was added to a cup of
coffee in the morning or glass of orange
juice would kill you within minutes
kratom was not the culprit here but the
fda withheld that information and did
not disclose it similarly when they made
their application to the drug
enforcement administration on october 17
of 19 2017
they they successfully got the dea to
consider scheduling kratom but they have
not disclosed for the past two and a
half years that on august the 16th of
2018 the department of health and human
services which is the official designee
to transmit such recommendations for
scheduling rescinded that application
for scheduling and specifically called
out the fda for failing to document by
the science the requirements for
scheduling and made a very interesting
point which i think is relevant to your
discussion the secretary the assistant
secretary of health said that
furthermore there is a significant risk
of immediate adverse public health
consequences for potentially millions of
users of creating words components are
included in schedule one now the reason
he he did that is because there are a
number of people who are successfully
using kratom as an option to and
replacement for opioids a johns hopkins
university study of adult kratom users
who use kratom for managing acute and
chronic pain reported that 87 percent of
those people using opioids using kratom
to get off of those opioids reported
significant relief from their withdrawal
symptoms
35 percent were opioid free within a
year now that is a a product that is
harm reduction that ought to be
celebrated not restricted but again it
goes to the intended use and the
individual that seeks to have that kind
of relief as a less harmful substance
ought to have the freedom to make that
choice not that a vendor should be able
to make the claim about that because
obviously that contradicts what is known
in the what is required for a new drug
application so the american kratom
association seeks to provide an access
point for consumers to make informed
decisions which is why labeling is asked
for in this particular legislation it is
why it is characterized as a food under
the food drug and cosmetic act and it is
why the fda's attacks on kratom really
should be replaced with a good
regulatory scheme which we think that
they will eventually get to the fda does
today appropriately regulate kratom
products that are mislabeled and we
support them in fact we report regularly
those creative manufacturers who are
using therapeutic claims inappropriately
they also are willing to respond to any
adverse events and we support that as
well largely those adverse events are
because of what we see with adulterated
kratom products that it is you cannot be
addicted to kratom in the classical
sense as you would expect for opioids
the national institutes on drug abuse
conducted two independent animal studies
which are the gold standard prediction
liability one of the requirements for
scheduling under the controlled
substances act and they determined two
things one there was no significant
addiction liability therefore uh the
fda's claim failed but they also
reported there was a significant
reduction in the cravings of the test
animals for the reference drug which was
morphine which validates why the new
national drug institutes on drug abuse
today supports the aka's position they
funded more than 15 million dollars in
studies into kratom and why the us
congress in the fy 20 and 21 legislation
reports that kratom should not be
scheduled and in fact should be studied
more and available to the public because
of all the reports they're having of
people that are benefiting from it
i know that you will hear a lot of the
hyped-up anti-creative information that
is generated by the fda but in our
research and all of our studies we have
found that that is the result of
adulterated products that should not be
on the marketplace and why this bill is
so important given the failure of the
fda to enforce the laws that they should
be enforcing but of those four states
that have already passed it we've seen
because of covet we had obviously a
disaster in the legislative solutions
sessions last year but this year we've
already seen significant progress the
missouri house of representatives passed
the kratom consumer protection act 144
to zero in oklahoma the committee passed
it out unanimously in wisconsin the
wisconsin senate health committee passed
unanimously opened a bill foul
unanimously in order to replace their
ban with a kratom consumer protection
act in the rhode island the public
health commissioner has opened a formal
review of kratom and to replace the
ban there with a kratom consumer
protection act because they are becoming
informed about the misinformation that
the fda has provided and that is
validated by the august 16 2018 letter
recently disclosed which attacks the
premise of the fda so we want to work
with you and we'll certainly work with
the food protection section of your
state government agencies in order to
come to a a good
regulatory scheme that they'll be
comfortable with it's working in other
states and we think it'll work in new
hampshire so with that i thank you for
this opportunity and certainly willing
to answer any questions you might have
uh we do have some questions
representative abramson has a question
thank you mr chair and uh thank you uh
mr hatto for for that testimony um so
this is the same question i asked the
sponsor it was it your intent
um
for the uh when you're the seller you
have a common law duty to disclose or
common law duty to notify is that your
your preference or intent on the
labeling the labeling of the product
when it's sold
that we have some type of statutory
scheme added to the bill or was it your
preference that we simply fall back on
the old uh
common law or or some other approach
well we would defer
representative abramson to the new
hampshire preference on this uh other
states have required specific labeling
of the contents of the product and we
certainly support that what we're
finding is that the legitimate vendors
are labeling it to the strictest
standard and so we're seeing a great
transformation in the kratom industry
that's very beneficial for consumers
where we're seeing accurate labeling
being applied to kratom products because
they're having to market them in a lot
of states now and and there's no reason
to have multiple labels unless you're a
bad actor and those of course the
manufacturers we would like to eliminate
but we're not opposed in any way in fact
we favor labeling that requires full
disclosure of the ingredients of the
product and that accurately portray the
contents of a kratom product that is
sold in your state all right thank you
very much
representative van halen
thank you and thank you sir for your
testimony uh i'd like to go right back
to the very basic question that i asked
a bit earlier to the sponsor is this
legal
and if it is legal where
and if not are we looking at a backdoor
effort to legalize it by overlooking the
fact that it's never been legalized
uh thank you representative
it is today as coffee is legal in every
state except for six that were initially
misled by the fda about the safety
profile of kratom which has been
completely debunked by the hhs letter of
of august 16 2018 which i would refer
you to read
that safety data reflects only
adulterated products the deaths every
death that's attributable to a craving
that the fda cites is actually because
of poly drug use or adulterated kratom
products uh there were two that did not
have blood samples uh that no one was
able to test but the national institute
institutes on drug abuse did their own
evaluation came to the conclusion that i
just articulated so from
from a legal basis kratom is sold
legally and in three of the six states
that banned it they're now
hopefully going to overturn those this
year
and we think eventually all of them will
follow suit but the four states that
have passed the kratom consumer
protection act simply put in a good
regulatory scheme to eliminate
adulterated products we're hoping to do
that in about we have it active in 30
states this year including new hampshire
so we're hopeful that we'll get many
more states following suit
i apologize uh thank you for that and
for that explanation uh is new hampshire
one of the six states in which this is
not legal
no
it is legal to be sold the six states
are alabama arkansas indiana wisconsin
rhode island and vermont
[Music]
i have heard that the town of franklin
has banned it
for the question you may inquire
um thank you when you say legal legal
for sale legal for use could you clarify
the term legal for me please possession
yeah thank you there's the three
criteria uh it is legal in the united
states except for those six states and
those six states have varying uh degrees
of whether it's legal for possession or
use or sale
it is legal in the united states for
sale uh it is legal for um for the use
in virtually every state and possession
i think in four of the six states it's
banned alabama's the toughest of those
states and i think it's illegal for
possession use or sale in the
in those
uh representative
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
do physicians prescribe
this product kratom
no physicians uh would
it's not a prescription medication and
until and if
kratom a kratom product were either
synthesized or approved by the the food
and drug administration as a
prescription product it would not be uh
but interestingly in the survey that was
done of kratom consumers in the united
states of which there are 15 million
40 reported that they consult with their
physician about using kratom we think
that number would go up dramatically if
the fda didn't have this sort of onus
that they put on it
and allow for a more accurate depiction
of the kratom product but we're
encouraged that so many people are
consulting their doctors as they use it
particularly for for pain relief uh
certainly the people use it for the the
uh the energy boost uh and increase
focus about a third of the population of
the 15 million do it for that third use
it for reducing anxiety and then that
other third use it for management and
pain and we think in that care the
category checking with your physician is
important
how about a follow-up yeah i was gonna
say how about natural pass
natural password
they love it i mean this is this is in
their wheelhouse and we have a strong
support from that community because it's
one of the tools that can effectively be
used uh in the plant community to help
people improve the quality of their
lives and manage their symptoms so could
someone purchase it as a homeopathic
medic medicine
yeah there's as you know uh chairman
hunt there's a categorization for
homeopathic remedies
right now the fda doesn't classify it
that way but it is considered an herbal
product so yes it could be a homeopathic
remedy okay go ahead representative
yeah thank you mr chair uh do you know
if this is sold on the black market oh
yes but not not the pure kratom it's the
adulterated kratom products and that's
exactly what uh one of the leading
scientists in the world addressed that
issue when he submitted an eight factor
analysis to the drug enforcement
administration that said that if you ban
kratom this was back in 2016 if you ban
kratom you will you will strengthen the
black market where adulterated products
flourish if people have access to
a pure kratom product that's
legitimately sold in your state they're
safer and here's here's the important
issue on that uh many people purchase
kratom and they don't know it's
adulterated and i hear reports of people
say oh it it made me feel really really
good for about six hours and i felt this
euphoric high that is an adulterated
craving product but they thought they
were buying a pure kratom product that's
what we want to eliminate as best we can
from the supply chain
yes thank you mr chairman um you had
mentioned a letter from
um hhs could you provide a copy of that
for us yes i sent a copy to everyone but
i'll do it again i might no if you sent
it i uh that's fine i i didn't see it
but thank you yeah and let me just tell
you one thing about this letter when you
look at it we have scoured the records
this is the first time in the history of
the of the controlled substances act in
the federal government that there has
ever been a withdrawal or recession
letter sent to the dea withdrawing a
recommendation first time and and that's
really significant because the hhs
assistant secretary of health really
looked at this looked at the science and
found the fda was wrong wrong on the
policy and wrong on the science and
that's articulated in his letter
and the fda kept it secret for two and a
half years so they could continue to uh
to put out their disinformation campaign
the day after this letter was sent to
the dea the fda commissioner was
tweeting about kratom being dangerous
and yet that was contraindicated by the
letter and the judgment of the science
done by the assistant secretary for
health
okay any other questions um
so mr i'm confused
um
why are you asking us to ban not having
sales to anyone under 18 if there's
nothing wrong with this stuff
well this to us the important thing is
that a child
should make a decision with their
parents because if they take a lot of
kratom if they were to buy it and not
responsibly use it and we believe that
everyone should do use kratom
responsibly as they would any other it's
like aspirin was mentioned earlier if
you get a whole cough syrup as another
one kids do things that sometimes are
dumb and so we think that having the
parents having a say in how much kratom
a kid could use there's no study that
shows that kratom is dangerous to kids
kids don't like it because unless it's
adulterated because of its taste um and
so all of that but we just think it's an
appropriate restriction that makes sure
that parents are participating in those
decisions
so are you saying to me that that
that a pharmacy cannot sell cough
medicine to kids
i i don't know what the law is in new
hampshire uh with respect to that but my
i think that if if my child were buying
cough medicine at a pharmacy or at a
grocery store with a pharmacy section
i'd want to participate in that decision
that's my personal i understand that but
but you're it just seems so weird that
you put this 18 you're you're making
this case that you know well it could be
it can be uh
some it's not really a drug it's a food
and uh the only food products that we
we require 18 year olds are the ones
that are cigarettes and alcohol and and
then we have a whole elaborate structure
to how to regulate that industry and
and we have no system to regulate kratom
right we have nobody in the state who's
going to know
what's altered creative and what's not
and so we really can't regulate that but
yet you're going to say but but we're
going to have some kind of regulation
about selling it to someone under 18
which we have you know we have this well
our whole liquor commission is built
around ensuring that that certainly you
know under 21 and it's 21 not 18 by the
way
so i just it seems really confusing to
me that that it sounds like you do admit
that this product can be abused
and really should be regulated
well
there's no question that kratom like
many other
substances that are freely available to
consumers can be abused we don't have
any doubt about that you would have to
consume a lot now the one thing that's
comforting i hope you'll take comfort in
is that the science demonstrates and
i've sent some articles and i'll be glad
to share some additional ones that even
at 100 times the consumption that a
human might consume of kratom in a day
there is no there's no respiratory
suppression and no deaths but that
doesn't mean that that it cannot become
you can't develop a dependency on it if
you overuse it or abuse it and so we
think that children ought to have the
regulation of a parent uh advising them
as best they can and so the in the way
that we regulate tobacco products and
alcohol different age limits that's sort
of the thinking behind it but we
recognize the reality is that the
children can use kratom uh and might but
they're we want them to think through
this decision and not abuse it and
that's our thinking behind it we
jettison it if you felt like that were
appropriate uh our key concern here is
eliminating adulterated kratom products
from the marketplace and that only
happens if the states will unify and
send the message clearly that they are
not going to tolerate adulterated
craving products to be sold in their
states
okay representative herbert has a
question
[Music]
yes i like
chairman hunt thank you
chairman hunt and and thank you for the
information uh mr hat uh i i didn't know
what kratom was until uh
today
but uh it where i have it i'm having
difficulty and i don't to try and figure
it out today
is that it sounds to me as though you
have a product
that
would be
should be
regulated and allowed to be sold
as a prescription of some sort and then
and then
because i you know all the nice things
you're talking about in terms of
relieving anxiety helping
mitigate pain etc etc
sounds to me like uh you're
it's almost like a homeopathic slash
bufferin slash aspirin
uh
fouls tasting something or other
i i think you have to you have to i
would i would would you believe i would
rather you convince the colleen smiths
of the world
uh to get you an entry pathway
uh that you can live with
but asking 20 uh state reps
here in concord uh is to me uh
an interesting exercise but uh very very
hard for me to
to
uh give you yes
i guess this is a belief
would you believe would you believe i
think you i think you have to convince
some other people
first all he has to do is convince this
i don't know you don't have to answer a
would you believe questions
thank you for the the issue that you've
raised here and i understand that you
may see a characterization here of it
being used in a prescription drug format
and i think that there is and the nastu
institute on drug abuse agrees with you
that there may be a potential
synthesized version of kratom which
would have a standard dosage strength
that would go through the new drug
application process which can be and the
director of nida has said it it can be
an option for and a replacement for
dangerously addictive and potentially
deadly opioids we think that potentially
is the future but that is in a
pharmaceutical grade product there are
many many products foods and and foods
is a categorization driven by the food
drug and cosmetic act but there are many
products on the market today that have
benefits that are not as concentrated as
a prescription drug has but yet are
available and people can use it to help
manage uh lower symptoms that they might
have on some of these anxiety issues and
pain issues and that's what kratom
offers and most of the of the
prescription drugs that we have today
have their origins in plants and this is
an example of a plant that's been used
safely for centuries and it needs to be
available in a safe form in its natural
plant form to consumers and we want to
eliminate from the marketplace these bad
actors so we hope you'll consider that
and understand there's a pathway in the
future for this becoming depending on
intended use by a manufacturer a dietary
supplement under the
dietary supplement notification process
or a new drug application
thank you
okay let's
represent immaculate
uh uh thank you mr chair
how just
mr haydow how actually would you
make sure that you had this purified
version coming into the state is there
is there a
a
you know some sort of a lab test that
you could do on it is there an existing
uh company that would do that and put
like a like with cigarettes a stamp on
it or something like that
so so the kratom raw material that's
used in the manufacturing of kratom
products here in the united states
originates in indonesia there's about
five percent that comes from thailand
and malaysia
it is tested by the manufacturers for
contaminants the adult duration occurs
here in the united states by
unscrupulous vendors so when a product
is sold in its pure firm form it has
gone through testing in order to make
sure it's free from those contaminants
that might be dangerous to consumers uh
the the idea that someone might want to
adulterate the product in order to give
it an effect that it does not naturally
have in order to then economically
benefit from increased sales is the area
that we're really concerned about in
protecting consumers because i as i
mentioned earlier many consumers buy
what they think is a pure product that
has been certified with a what they call
a certificate of analysis from an
independent uh lab testing firm to make
sure it's free of those contaminants
they think they're buying pure kratom
and what they're getting is an
adulterated product and that's why we
think this is important for consumers to
be protected because right now there's
well thank you
all right any other questions for mr
hatto
mr chan with your permission i'll send
some additional information to each of
the of the committee members
some of the questions i'll be glad to do
that would be great we appreciate having
anything you can send us that would be
great
okay and
um i see another hand up uh oh kate fry
okay so uh kate did you sign up i didn't
oh
i didn't expect you to weigh in on this
one but i wasn't planning to weigh in on
a
chairman hunt so i had not signed up and
i apologize no problem me okay yep we
can it's saying i'm muted um i we
actually uh new future is not taking a
position on this bill we've been
watching it and monitoring it from from
afar and attending some hearings
but i guess i had the same question that
you did regarding the age and the
regulation
and i'm going to say this because this
committee has done a lot of great work
on issues like tobacco control and we
did increase that age to 21. and you
have to be 21 to drink we also know a
lot of the issues around addiction and
that sensitive age period of 18 to 21 so
i'm really curious why
the um sponsor the bell chose 18 i did a
quick search again i'm not familiar with
this issue very much um a state i
looks like tennessee
has it at 21 so
um if you go down that road i would
seriously consider why you would be
selecting an age of 18 when we know
18 to 21 is critical with
brain development there's a lot we don't
know about kratom and i would just uh
caution you to be
cautious
and that's all i want to say and i
apologize again for not signing up all
right so i guess that was my fault for
mentioning the 21
all right well thank you very much kate
all right uh seeing no more hands up on
my in the attendees list
and
so i will end the public hearing
on house bill 333 uh we had 25 people in
support we had four people opposed and
nobody and nobody's neutral on it and
with that we will close the public
hearing and we are behind schedule now
officially okay
so the last but not least is house bill
so i'll ask the sponsor i see your chuck
i'm gonna
and
apologize for being late
a trouble at all mr chairman not a
problem at all
um thank you mr chairman
i'm here today
house
five uh which is a bill relative to the
labeling of bottled water
uh this bill originally came in under a
different name uh two sessions ago
i introduced it uh as a with mindy
representative mindy messier
and it was a bill to require the
labeling of bottled water here in new
hampshire
the last two years
um
consumer reports has done studies on the
quality of our drinking water and
particularly bottled water in 2019
november 2019 they
um
they did a very comprehensive report on
the quality of our bottled water
with the advent of pfas
and a number of other contaminants that
here in new hampshire we've been very
aggressively addressing
in fact
people have looked at bottled water as a
safe haven
let's say when they have concerns
of the quality of their drinking water
uh we have adopted some very good
standards but still we have a long way
to go
and one of the things that uh when we
originally introduced this bill we felt
that it was something that people needed
to know what was in their bottled water
last session it was house bill 1274
which was before your committee
and you took it under advisement and you
decided to amend it to
take care of the legalities as far as
federal regulations were concerned as
far as new hampshire that it would be
just for
basically that any bottled water in the
state sold in the state of new hampshire
would have to meet state of new
hampshire drinking water quality
standards
i think
that's the least we can do for those
parents who depend on bottled water as a
safe source of drinking water i mean the
best we could do is to label it so they
would know what was in their water but
we may not be able to actively do that
but what we can do is we can require
that the minimum drinking water
meets the drinking water minimum to meet
state standards
your committee took on an advisement
amended the bill
totally happy with that as far as it's
something that we can get into
application it passed the house last
year was approved by this committee
passed the house and it sort of died on
the covert floor in the senate last year
uh which was unfortunate but it's
something that we hopefully we can
correct this year getting this bill
through i know the department of health
and human services has also suggested
another amendment i would support i have
a chance to quickly review that and
i certainly would support it anything
that they can do
that they feel they need to make this
bill more enforceable
is certainly welcome
it's a start
and it's a start in the right direction
and it may be satisfactory for most
people to know that at least the bottled
water that they're buying the stores
meets requirements my understanding is
and talking with lobbyists that those
manufacturers within the state of new
hampshire have no problem with this bill
some out-of-state manufacturers do when
you take a look at the amount of efas
and some water that comes into the state
it's signific it is significant
and this is water which we have no
control over so maybe we want to take a
look at if they want to sell in the
state of new hampshire they'll have to
meet state standards i'll try to anthony
questions you have mr chairman
uh i don't think so i did do you have
any evidence that we've had any bottled
water in this state that actually did
have pfas or any or anything that did
not meet our water standards is there
any evidence that that we've ever had
bottled water problem
i will i will tell you that according to
the uh consumer reports articles they
list a number of bottled waters that
have pc pfast levels of above certain
levels and below certain levels and they
list the names of those companies i will
be happy to send those companies that
list to the committee
okay and i assume these are bottled
waters that are available in new
hampshire some of them are available in
new hampshire some of them are not
available here they actually in one
category they list here they actually
have a poland spring water that is as a
relatively high level of bottled water
um of pfast in the water so it's
something that we'd want to take a look
at now that may have been cleaned up and
hopefully companies do clean up their
water but we don't know that's the thing
right so this bill requires you to send
uh tests on how regular basis right if
there's a problem with the water how
regularly supposed to be sending sampler
tests
to the to the department
it it there is a they've said the
department of health and human services
will be centered rules and regulations
dealing with that uh that they will make
that determination on how many times
they shall have to comply with with
testing okay so you're saying this is
consumer report weren't the ones
consumer report one point time saying
new york city water was the best water
to drink actually yeah they were and i
mean that was a that's an old study but
it's a matter of clean water i mean a
lot of bottled water manufacturers here
in the state of new hampshire get the
water from londonderry right from the
tap
and they add a few chemicals to a few
minerals to it to enhance the flavor but
it comes right out of the tap of
londonderry and that's good to know as
long as londonderry
which i assume they have to submit the
water to be tested yes
okay anyway okay representative abramson
i'm sorry i was trying to lower my hand
you you asked the question oh okay i'm
too fast for you okay representative
thank you chairman
um
so am i to understand uh mr grassi that
uh
the
bill that was passed
last year
uh
there is an amendment that you
you're fine with that bill
but there's an amendment that the
department would like to see in it and
so we're very close to having a bill
that
uh will pass and and satisfy your
uh your desires to have cleaner water or
better water or whatever
is that where we are thank you for the
question yes the bill that that i
introduced this year was the bill that
came out of this committee last year you
folks took the original ballot bill you
amended it based on recommendations from
dhhs and others and you amended it and
the bill passed out of this committee to
the floor and was passed by the house
um dhhs has said they would like some
additional amendments i just found out
about that this weekend and i i
briefly scan them i have no problems
with it basically it helps them as far
as setting up their rule making process
let me
thank you mr chairman
uh representative grassy
uh londonderry water
that comes through the pipe comes from
the dairy water system
which comes from the manchester water
works which is one of the ten top
aquifer systems
in the united states would you believe
i i would believe that and i will tell
you one thing because we had here in
rochester i'm from we also have a uh we
have our water which is which is
basically from reservoirs instead of
aquifers reservoirs tend to have fewer
problems with bfast than aquifers do but
i understand that the system over there
is
is quite complex how the water circles
around and eventually comes out of your
tap it does come from manchester from
the major uh reservoirs and afterwards
that they do have
okay okay thank you very much uh
representative muse
you were are you a co-sponsor or you're
yes sir thank you very much mr chairman
my name is representative david muse i'm
from portsmouth and i'm just here to
lend my full support to this bill
um portsmouth
uh like many new hampshire communities
has found itself on the wrong side of
water contamination several times
throughout its history one of the things
that's a little bit unique about my
community is that we find found
ourselves on both sides of the issue
we have been
both the victim of the negligence of
another party uh over at uh peace trade
port
and we've also been a responsible party
um
in coakley landfill uh responsible for
uh the contamination of of of water uh
this affected water supplies in
greenland northampton and rye
uh so one of the things that we're
pretty familiar with are bottled water
and
and i think one of the things that i've
seen over the years
is just the the anxiety and the
consternation on the part of people who
all of a sudden find out that their
water supply um is contaminated
and
and i think the one thing that that
pretty much all of them accept as the
gold standard
is that the water that's provided to
them the bottled water that's provided
to them and while their their own water
supply is offline
uh is actually cleaner than the water
that would be coming out of their tap
and
one of the things that happened uh just
a couple of years ago there was an
incident where a company called spring
hill farms out of haverhill
massachusetts was bottling water uh for
companies like uh uh store brand water
for companies like whole foods cbs
market basket uh and cumberland farms
and the peat fast levels in those in
that water actually exceeded the former
federal standards so 70 parts per
trillion we're not talking about the
state standards that were recent
reasonably passed this water didn't even
pass muster under the under the federal
standards so this is something that has
happened in new hampshire and one of the
things that representative uh grassley
recommend uh actually said during his
testimony is that consumer reports has
actually gone out and uh requested uh
water uh water reports uh from over 200
companies that sell bottled water uh and
they also did their own spa testing and
as a result of some of that uh spot
testing uh there actually were several
brands that had to uh or they chose to
remove their brands from the market
because they had levels of chemicals in
them not just pfas but chemicals like
antimony uh and arsenic um that were
also above the standards so this this is
not sort of a shot in the dark situation
that that happens every once in a while
um
this is something that that has happened
um that will probably happen again
and one of the things i think that i
remember from last year's testimony is
there were folks from the uh
international bottled water association
that came in and talked about
the rigorous standards that they have
and and essentially how the the industry
likes to police themselves
one of the issues that we found in the
case of the the spring hill valley
contamination is that
they were not members of the
international bottled water association
and not every company is so
essentially
i'm here to say
looking at the statute that's in front
of you now uh it looks much simpler and
much more straightforward than the one
that we had in front of you one of you
last year it really requires um that
that
um uh
that uh
that you know we we review the um
uh that that essentially bottled water
companies comply uh with the same
standards uh as our our public drinking
water standards uh and you know to me it
just makes common sense uh that we would
do that and that we would require that
um and i'll
okay i guess we're
we're all set
past three three o'clock hour people are
slowing down
okay thank you very much thank you uh so
uh
you know it calmly smells like i can't
believe i moved you off and then i'd
take to turn the page and see you're
still there so um i'm glad i was able to
schedule these two bills right next to
each other so that you could testify to
both of them
so i realized the department is neutral
but you did say you want to share some
stuff
thank you chairman hunt and members of
the committee again for the record my
name is colleen smith i'm the
administrator of the food protection
section within the department of health
and human services and i'm here today to
provide some background information
regarding the current regulation of
bottled water in new hampshire and
available to answer any questions that
you have pertaining to these regulations
so the food protection section within
dhhs we currently license and inspect
all in-state manufacturers of bottled
water and we register annually all
out-of-state manufacturers of bottled
water who distribute bottled water in
new hampshire
we would like to let you know that we
are initiating rule making
that would also
require bottled water to meet the same
standards as drinking water standards in
new hampshire
particularly the the requirements for
the four pfos
substances and also arsenic so we are
hoping to complete this rule making by
this summer um and we have started to
alert our stakeholders of of this
upcoming rule change
we are very happy to hear that
representative grassy is amenable to a
suggested language change and it's a
very small change
to this current
bill which would just clarify that we
are intending this
this to apply to only water that's for
retail sale in new hampshire and not for
retail sale in other states so that
suggested language is in my written
testimony which was distributed to the
committee in advance
so with that i'd be happy to take any
other questions
regarding bottled water regulations
right so you already have statutory
authority to go ahead with this
rulemaking
so currently the the bottled water
standards are in our administrative
rules and they refer to
the standard that's standards that are
in the code of federal regulations and
within rulemaking we would just be
looking to add
those
that are
different which are the four pfos
contaminate contaminants or substances
and the arsenic those are the only
differences
in the drinking water standards and the
okay so i'm confused so i i'm saying do
you have you know
again do we why do we need this bill if
you're going ahead with the rulemaking
and implementing it already
so
um that that's
a great question it like i guess uh
there would probably there's there we
have to go through the rule making
process there could be stakeholder um
there could be stakeholder
that come out in the public hearing that
perv that prevent this but this would be
two i guess two ways to get at the the
same end result if if it was so um
deemed that it should be in statute as
well okay and when do you plan to do the
the hearings the rule hearings and when
the rules so
we have just started the process those
public hearings would be scheduled
within the next few months
so if we were to retain this bill till
next september we'll know whether there
was any pushback or any problems
yes that would be correct
okay
representative abramson has a question
uh thank you mr chair and thank you for
um how is this enforced do you just
randomly sample uh bottles
and uh what happens if someone fails you
know one of the tests is there an appeal
or a certain period of time before they
have to do another test
so our intention within
within our rule would be to ask that
bottled water manufacturers submit
proof of having their water anal
analyzed for these components with their
registry annual registration
from an accredited lab
okay so all all
their entire supply of water um
oh yeah further question um so my second
question was
um you mentioned that you would make the
habits make the small change that it
doesn't apply to water that is exported
or sold to other states wouldn't it
the purpose or a purpose of this bill
would be that the water that we sell if
it's made in new hampshire at least
any new hampshire bottled water meets
our standards kind of try to increase
the value of water that's sold in new
hampshire or maybe
no no um just to clarify so in-state
manufacturers would have to comply with
the same standards as drinking water
it's just that the way this the bill is
worded there could be confusion to say
that our rules would apply to these
autostate bottled water manufacturers
regardless if they're selling in new
hampshire or other states so we we just
want a clarifying language that this
requirement is only for their products
sold in new
hampshire a quick follow-up
further question you may inquire
so are you saying that your
preference is that this would apply only
to water that's sold in new hampshire or
water that's
made that's
made in new hampshire and then sentences
i'm saying that she doesn't want to
regulate water that is made in maine and
shipped to new york
she only cares about if it is sold in
thanks very much mr chair um thanks ms
smith you've been here a long day today
um
my question is how long has dhhs been
looking at this issue regarding
require the
in-state bottlers
comply with the regulations
so our timing on this was aligning with
the the change into the drinking water
standards so so um you know just within
the recent years and for those those
standards to become um official in
regulation from the drinking water
standpoint so once that uh once that was
finalized then we started to move
forward with looking at bottled water to
comply with the same standards
for the question manquer thanks very
much um
so can you give me some kind of a
timeline because i think we had the pfas
um discussion a couple of years ago and
you were looking at it at that time too
so one of the one of the things that we
had to wait for was for these to become
um official regulations for drinking
water and there were some there was some
so does that mean this is good
sorry
so does that mean
the process is now
clear and it can move right forward and
we don't need the bell or should we i'm
not going to ask you whether we should
move forward with the bill but i'm i'm a
little concerned about the timeline
yeah so sorry so there so there were
some regulatory challenges with the rule
in the department of environmental
services uh there there was um there had
to be an actual those started in rule if
if you recall those standards for
drinking water and then they were put
into statute last in la the last session
and so we had to wait for that process
to be complete before we look to update
the bottled water standards so we're
hopeful now that those are in place in
statute and in rural for drinking water
there's there's not a reason for us not
to be able to move forward with our
rulemaking
okay representative
thank you mr chairman uh thank you for
taking for taking my question ms smith i
know it's been a very long day
my question is on
21 cfr 165 110 b
are the
mcls the five mcls embedded in that or
is that in addition to
so those five
mcls are not in the cfr that's why we
would want to add them
either in statute or rule
thank you
okay great thank you very much uh miss
fest and i really appreciate you being
here for these two bills
no problem thank you
and that and last but not least or i do
have another attendee but is um james
tonner
until you're on jim
you just have to unmute yourself there
you go
thank you good afternoon i'm james toner
director of government relations for the
international bottled water association
i think you've heard us mention a few
times here and we thank you for the
opportunity to testify on house bill 35
although we consider ourselves neutral
on the bill uh ibwa still has concerns
over the precedent which set
imposing new hampshire safe uh drinking
water accuracily regulations on a
product manufactured outside of the
state interferes with interstate
commerce and we put out of state
bottlers at a disadvantage when trying
to sell a product in the state
the epa sets drinking water standards
for the nation and allows states to
impose standards that may differ or be
stricter than what has been set
nationally that is due to the fact that
the state water oversight only applies
to water within a state does not apply
to drinking water in any other state or
country
the fda set standards for bottled water
and while they follow the epa in regard
to their standards they do not follow
the individual states they do not allow
for individual states to impose
standards that are greater than that was
imposed by the fda
states have attempted to do this and
have been notified by the fda that they
have exceeded their jurisdiction and
that the national standard for bottled
water is set by the fda
i state that we are neutral on this bill
because ibw members are already required
to meet standards set by our code of
practice ibwa's code of practice with
regard to the standards
uh to several contaminants is stricter
than fda and we are allowed to do this
as a bottler does not have to be a
member of ibwa but if they wish to they
must comply with the association
standards this includes testing for
contaminants that are not currently
addressed by either epa or fda such as
pfas
or mtbe
we believe that ibwa's code of practice
covers all the requirements set within
the new hampshire sales safe drinking
water act but nine ibw members
may likely not be testing for everything
covered by the act and solely operate
based upon fda requirements but they
know they are completely within the
national standards based upon the fda
guidelines
is our suggestion that the committee
report the bill and expediate to
legislate in an effort to avoid possible
conflict with fda on bottled water
oversight and jurisdiction thank you
thank you we do have a question
of course
representative bartlett thanks very much
mr chair
okay um
i have a tough time with your saying
that you are neutral on this because it
um from your testimony it sounds like
you don't want more regulation um on the
standards
um and that if as a yes or no question
it does not sound that like you are
supporting this bill
i'm not supporting it but i'm not
opposed to it because our members are
already complying with the regulations
you have set in the state but what
you're doing is is against what fda
requirements are and i'm it's more of a
kind of a caveat that if you go down
this path you will get notified by the
fda that you don't have a jurisdiction
as a state to do this
the question is do we not have the
jurisdiction to regulate what's going to
other states or do we not have
jurisdictions you don't have the
jurisdiction to regulate
a bottled water that's being
bottled at a neighboring state coming
into your state you cannot require that
bottled water
to meet the standards that new hampshire
okay
and this is a
federal preempt this is federal
guidelines
are preemption that that we we state
cannot
uh
it's it's the standards that are over
you know i think you look at it kind of
this way you know that that the
it is it is interstate commerce is the
issue here uh in that even though uh
a bottler who is not in your state
follows all the fda guidelines uh that
they are acquired to uh but then they're
not allowed to sell in your state
because they have to meet the
requirements you have in your state that
well that's it'll be interesting
okay representative abramson you have a
question
thank you mr chair and thank you mr
toner for taking my question um
uh where would we find the uh federal
guidelines is that listed on the fda's
website or is that a federal yes yeah
you can find the guidelines both both
epas and fda's guidelines in terms of
what they require for testing
contaminants on both their websites
as well actually you could go to ibwa's
website and look at our code of practice
that we compare uh ebas fdas and ours uh
there's a full list of them
all right thank you very much cool
everybody all set
uh as often happens we have another hand
that pops up and uh former
representative messmer
mindy feels like uh feels like you i've
sponsored this bill originally like six
years ago or something
that's right
what's up welcome back to the congress
committee
thank you so much uh thank you for
taking my testimony and thank you for
hearing this important bill as you just
stated i did
sponsor with representative grassy the
first
iteration of this bill a few years ago
and interestingly enough after that
first bill was sponsored went through
the legislature
the state of new hampshire as mentioned
by representative muse
des did go out and sample about 30
bottled water companies in the state of
new hampshire
randomly they just picked 30. and five
of those samples came back with pfas
levels above our current mcls right now
and some were even above as represented
the epa number so clearly the the
compliance of bottled water companies
with
epa standards was not being adhered to
and certainly that was discovered in the
state of new hampshire that company
immediately i believe went out of
business is no longer selling bottled
water in new hampshire but
the
i ask you to support this bill even
though rulemaking may be going on
there's still no official notice of the
food service people and the
rulemaking but because this is the
language
says that bottled water in new hampshire
should adhere to
our drinking water mcls and so that
covers more than just
the pfas that it appears the rulemaking
may cover along with the arsenic that
the rulemaking may cover
it
is more flexible in that as new drinking
water levels are passed and promulgated
in the state of new hampshire that the
bottled water companies would have to
keep up with those including
mtve which was
one of the i think it was 2015 where new
hampshire passed a pretty
strict enforcement of mtbe
on drinking water in the state of new
hampshire and so it would also cover
things like mtbe which it doesn't sound
like the drinking water the bottled
water rule making that the food service
people are doing right now would cover
um so i guess the crux of this is is you
know we have decided in new hampshire
what is safe for people to drink in new
hampshire and as representative grassy
said when people like all of the people
in the merrimack bedford litchfield area
people live in portsmouth when they feel
that and know that their drinking water
provided to them is unsafe and they're
provided bottled water by the state of
new hampshire and want to go to the
store and buy bottled water to protect
their families to be in compliance while
we're sorting through
liability issues with the industrial
polluters they should be able to
know and understand and rely upon the
safety of the bottled water that
actually the bottled water they're
getting is as safe as the state of new
hampshire says is safe
for instance you could buy bottled water
right now bottled in massachusetts and
it may have levels of arsenic and mtbe
higher
than the tap water in our state is
allowed to serve you by your water
supplier so i think this is a very
important bill
i would say you know it's been a very
long time there still is no public
notice around the rule making these
could go into effect by june of this
year if the governor
signed this into law and that would put
you know the drinking water the bottle
drinking water of all these people who
are stressed and worried about their
public water supplies uh feeling that
they are water that the bottled water is
safe for them and their families to
consume so i ask you to please pass this
i said but it is true that the bill asks
for rulemaking anyways
so
we don't we don't want them to wait
around with the making we want to go
steam full steam ahead and and not wait
for us to pass the legislation and that
they'd have an effective date you know
who knows effective date 60 days after
passage that when they when we better to
wait to see what happens in that ruling
process and see what what hurdles were
created that we might want to address
can i respond to that yes like i said
this is more broad in in terms of you
know not just the pfas and the mt and
the arsenic levels that they're going to
maybe set but this covers
you know making sure that the bottled
water and drinking water regulations
line up in the state of new hampshire
right okay
uh representative has a question for you
oh i was just taking my hand down that
okay
i have uh no more oh i do have another
hand up so thank you very much mindy
uh so i have cynthia walter i am the
promote to pants so for you guys you do
know how to do the new sign up process
go ahead you know choke it would be if
you had signed up ahead of time then it
would be handy handier so but
there you go okay i got the unmuted uh
sorry i was trying it couldn't get the
button to work so yes i'm cynthia walter
i have a phd i've been teaching
toxicology and my specialty is water
pollution
um i hardly endorse this bill again
because it covers
not only the current rulemating rule
making plans regarding a few important
pollutants but it also addresses things
in the future it signals water suppliers
that either draw their water from new
hampshire and or draw their water from
other parts of the country
to um
that what we require for our bottled
water in our state
we need to do this first and foremost
just because of the same old adage
safety first
and this tells your decisions today um
going forward with this bill tell the
citizens and also then these companies
where we stand in new hampshire on
safety first
the other feature that i'd like to add
they encourage you to do is to expand
beyond bottled water because it
specifies in here products but it
doesn't distinguish
it doesn't open up the door to saying
that other
um
water
based products um you know drinks of
various mixtures um need also to provide
some of those safety uh features
so i'm not sure just how you came to the
words
bottled water and how you define that
but
i'd like to see it expanded
to other drink products
you know well so so you're if you're
besides so i think the other brothers
uh would say the coca-cola and pepsi
they have they uh the uh osmosis or
something something
the osmosis though or what is it what is
that term um they use the word first
osmosis excuse me reverse osmosis is
what you're thinking of yeah so are you
saying that water is not needs to be
tested too
well what i'm saying is is that because
we don't
say that the other products that
originate
in new hampshire and as there are
compiled and manufactured and sold
either within new hampshire
you know as as are sold within new
hampshire
that when the final finished product has
to meet
those standards
so we understand that the bottle water
needs to meet those five products
because water bottled water is probably
defined as the finished product
but when we have to simply expand to the
finished product of an orange drink or
you know some other drink
does that make sense but i'm not saying
that this bill needs to be rewritten in
that broader sense i'm just saying let's
get this bill done
to make bottled water as safe as it can
be
and signal the industry um that this is
where new hampshire stands
move ahead with the rulemaking which is
great but limited to only a few
substances at a time and kind of has to
work in reverse almost um
and then
then my suggestion is to go forward
and
continue with the
liquids
safety
guidelines
for the next bill that you might have
okay um if you're willing to take a
question uh representative emman has
can you hear me now
yes we can yeah thank you for taking my
question uh i guess i was trying to
understand
how you would like this bill to be
expanded and i was trying to think of
what other products might this apply to
would it apply to things like beer
because there's a lot of water and beer
or water ice water ice has a lot of
water in it
[Music]
i was just trying to think of what all
this might
apply to is just so that we make sure
everyone is
you know
applies to safety first
right so all i'm saying is is that i my
suggestion is
let's get the first thing done and the
bill as it's written
again with that clarification of of
where the bot water is made and sold
that was suggested by a previous speaker
that is fine so i suggest you move ahead
with this bill for this legislative
session
then
in another legislative session
i suggest
this committee or other committees
would look into
the idea of securing
standards
for
finished liquid products that are drawn
from
new hampshire waters that's
okay all
another session
right but he's asking you such as beer
like are you worried about beer
well i have to look into the issue of
beer and whether or not there's already
legislation associated with the
standards associated with beer
chemistry i
i'm not aware of that legislation right
now so i'd have to say let's look into
it for another legislative session
okay so what other water products do you
think is that you do are aware of
that yeah i i only know this build so
right so i just want to work with one
thing at a time maybe i should have made
that suggestion for next year open up
canada worms like that that's for next
year that's for next year please next
year
okay so we do have questions you'll be
willing to take some questions
and uh representative bartlett is first
yeah i got a little confused on the
direction you were going here um
thank you for allowing me to ask your
question one of the things our sign up
sheets um don't allow for or our
testimony is where people are from
um and with the virtual um
with our remote um
type hearings these days um we're
getting people from further and further
away can i just ask where you're from
oh yes i have lived here in dover for um
over a year
does that help
thank you very much
sure is i'm sorry i should have said
that when i started it's okay thanks
very much
okay so chuck i'm gonna let you go last
because it's sort of a wrap up so but uh
so we'll go uh representative abramson
i assume you're asking this question to
um
miss walter
yeah um that that
uh beer question did bring up another
issue there are a lot of
bottled water products that are
have very light flavoring or very light
coloring
if somebody is trying to i always think
of rules in terms of somebody's trying
to weasel out of it they have water that
doesn't pass that could they you know
kind of weasel out of this role just by
adding some coloring or sugar or
something else and then selling it as uh
you know like a crystal like type of
would would this role apply to
colored and flavored products
uh i don't think she would be able to
answer that question but i'm sure chuck
will try to stat take a stab at it when
when i invite him back up
uh
in representative fargo you still got a
question
um thank you mr chairman it's more of a
would you believe um cynthia walter is
from my ward here in dover so i just
want to say that if she would like to
talk to me about further legislation i
would be open to having that discussion
okay so call your rep cynthia
yes thanks
all right i think i'm getting everybody
so i'm going to um allow
representative gracie to have the last
word i i just didn't want to respond to
that last question about uh other types
of water that she brought up and one of
the things that the consumer reports
studies and both times they stated was
that it tells the waters
a very have very high contaminated
levels far above what we would allow in
any of our waters here in new hampshire
that's another day that's another story
i don't know when representative
abramson's question about if they added
a little bit of coloring to it i don't
know
that's something i would have to talk to
dhs about but certainly in my research
when i noticed that
you know we dealt with water this was a
bill that came in as you said six years
ago when we were just trying to move
this through because it died on the
floor last year
delsa waters may be something different
that we have to take a look at i don't
know
and if it is we will be bringing in a
bill that will deal with that because
certainly they found some significant
contaminations particularly with pfas
and arsenic in selsa waters
don't even have to go to beer and we may
not want to go there but um ruin it for
all of us uh but the thing is is that
those are something we may want to take
we're looking at health products here
things that people look at as being
healthy and pure some people like a
little fizz in their water not an
alcohol product
thank you mr chairman
okay
thank you um all right well with that we
will uh close the public hearing and
then i will read the numbers here
uh we had 148 in support
11 opposed
two are neutral
and with that we'll close the public
hearing on house bill 335
and
uh i guess
i guess we're all done for the day
anybody have any other questions or
comments
thank you hey john